NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBE AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH.
STONE TEAM MELENDEZ BE APPROVED
WHAT VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. I WANT TO
GUARD. WE BELIEVE YOU ARE TO
GIVE HER A PIECE. AND YOU ARE
SUFFICIENT FOR US. WE ASK YOU
OF YOUR PIECE SO WE CAN SHARE
IT WITH OTHERS. THROUGH THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE ON THIS
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. GUIDE US ON THE
PATH OF MAKING THIS WORLD A
PEACEFUL PLACE FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME. I MEAN. THANK YOU MA
YES SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER LUCKY MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE SUMMER.
AFTER ME. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. STATES WHERE-
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION.
ISRAEL YEAH STRONG. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
SOLUTIONS SEGMENT USER BEFORE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS IN THE
MINUTE SEVEN AM BE ON THE
LOOKOUT FOR DONALD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEVENTH DISTRICT
RESIDING CHIEF CLERK SUPPORTER
OF THE DEATH READING FOR DAVID
BOWMAN READING ROLL CALL THE
FOLLOWING REPLACE ON THE
MORNING ROLL CALL SEVENTY EIGHT
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA DARKY AND
BEEN IS A RAMOS MOVES AND MR.
LACKEY SECONDS. THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. PARTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
ABSENCES FOR TODAY'S SESSION.
AND MS REYES.
UHHUH UHHUH.
EXACTLY I SAID THE REQUESTED
THEM. M. IS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER TO HAVE GUESTS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LACKEY GONZALEZ
ON FLORA TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AND I MOVE
TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRUE TO TAKE UP
AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADOPTING FLOOR
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AND THEN
TAKING UP THE BILL AS AMENDED
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
PASSAGE. MISS DAVIES. WEAVER
RECOMMENDATION OBJECT PASSING
OVER THE FILE NOTICES AND NOT
PROVIDING ADEQUATE TIME FOR THE
PUBLIC TO REVIEW THE NEARLY GOT
AN AMENDED BILLS. WE OBJECT.
THANK YOU MISS DAVIS MISS DAVIS
IS WITHHOLDING. UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. MEMBERS THIS IS A
RULES SUSPENSION PROCEDURAL
VOTE MS REYES MOVES. AND.
MISTER BLOOM SECONDS. ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS. CARPAL
OPEN THE ROLE. ISRAEL IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISS DAVIES IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS. MISS
DAVIES IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SORRY MISS DAVIS IS
ASKING. FOR MISS DAVIES AND NO.
ON THE PROCEDURAL MATTER. THIS
TAKES FORTY ONE MEMBERS.
ISRAEL
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND
MISS DAVIES AND NOW.
CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL EYES FORTY TWO KNOWS
FOURTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GUESTS WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO MR JONES SAWYER IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FROM MY
DESK MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- TODAY I RISE
WITH PLEASURE AND GRATITUDE.
AND FOR BOTH OF YOU MAY NOT
KNOW HIM. BUT HE'S BEEN
IDENTICAL PART OF PUBLIC SAFETY
AND IT'S PROBABLY OPINE ON
EVERY PUBLIC SAFETY BILL THAT
YOU EVEN DREAMED UP OR THOUGHT
OF. IT TO BID UP BOB FOND
FAREWELL TO A CRITICAL MEMBER
OUR ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY FAB.
MISTER GREGORY PAGAN. NOW FOR
THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS GREG HAS
SERVED AS CHIEF COUNSEL ON THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. I GUESS SPENT ALL OF
HIS TWENTY THREE YEARS IN STATE
SERVICE AS COUNSEL TO THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE SERVING THE LAST
SIXTEEN AS OUR CHIEF COUNSEL.
AS CHIEF COUNSEL GREG WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO SHEPHERD
LEGISLATION THAT HOLDS TRUE TO
OUR VALUES OF CALIFORNIANS.
GREG HIS LEAD MENTOR AND MOLDED
THE VERY BEST OF OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF. MEMBER IN AND MENTORED
MOST OF THE SENATE STAFF IN
PUBLIC SAFETY ENSURING THAT IF
NOTHING ELSE THIS HOUSE PASSES
LEGISLATION THAT PROMOTES
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS WITHIN THE
LAW. FOR THOSE OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHOSE BILLS HAVE. EITHER BEEN
GUTTED OR MADE IT THROUGH. MY
COMMITTEE ARE NOT MADE IT
THROUGH MY COMMITTEE. YOU CAN
BLAME NONE OTHER THAN GRAY. IT
WAS ALL HIS FAULT. OF COURSE IF
YOU BILLS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
PASSED OUT OF MY COMMITTEE THAT
WAS ALL ME. REGGIE IN ALL
SERIOUSNESS I TRULY APPRECIATED
THE YEARS OF WORKING WITH GRAY
AS WE COLLABORATE ON PASSING
LONG OVERDUE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORMS THAT RESTORE DIGNITY TO
THOSE IMPACTED BY THE
DISCRIMINATORY TOUGH ON CRIME
POLICIES OF OUR PAST AND I WILL
SURELY MISS OUR COMMITTEE
BRIEFING DEBATES REGRET WHAT
ALWAYS GIVES SAGE ADVICE.
HISTORICAL CONTEXT AND USED THE
KEEPER OF THE SECRETS OF THE
ASSEMBLY. BRAG YOUR DILIGENCE
AND DEDICATION TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE HAS NOT HAS NOT GONE
UNNOTICED AND COUNTLESS PIECES
OF LEGISLATION THAT YOU HAVE
TOUCH WILL LAST FOREVER LASTING
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
MANY CALIFORNIANS DEVOTION TO
THIS BODY AND COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY IN THE LAW. IS FOREVER
ENSHRINED IN HIS BODY. I HEARD
THAT YOU'RE EXPECTING YOUR
FIRST GRAND CHILD. AND AS A
GRANDPA FOR MYSELF I CAN TELL
YOU YOUR THAT YOUR TIMING
COULDN'T BE BETTER. MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THANKING GREG PAGAN AND HIS
LOVELY WIFE LORI PAGAN TO SHOW
TO PUT UP WITH ALL THIS FOR ALL
THESE YEARS. FOR THEIR SERVICE
TO THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
PIN COMMITTEE. AND LET US ALL
WISH HIM A WELL DESERVED
RETIREMENT. HOLD ON THE PROJECT.
YEAH. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE COVERAGE
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY THIRTEEN
WITH THE MINISTRY NINETEEN
THREE THIRTY THREE WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN WITH A
MINUTES FIVE NINETY SIX OF THE
MOMENT SEVENTY TWO WITH A
MINUTES THREE THIRTY FOR THE
MEMBERS TO READY FOR THE MOMENT
A LOT OF THE MINUTES. TWO
EIGHTY THREE SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY FOR THE MEMBERS AND
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY THREE
WITH A MENACE. ALL BILLS WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WEIRD
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE WE
HAVE. AMENDMENTS MR CHIU HAS
AMENDMENTS. ON AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO. THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE THE A MAN'S ON EIGHT.
THIRTY TWO. THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU MISTER CHILL ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES COLLEAGUES AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES AN
ADDICTION CRISIS THAT LOOMS OF
CURRENT PROTECTIONS ARE NOT
EXTENDED BEYOND JUNE THIRTIETH
WHICH IS THIS WEDNESDAY.
DESPITE VACCINATIONS AND THE
ECONOMY RE OPENING MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL IN
PRECARIOUS FINANCIAL SITUATIONS.
TENANTS MANY STRUGGLING WITH
SKYROCKETING RENTS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC HAVE BORNE THE BRUNT
OF UNPRECEDENTED JOB LOSSES
DURING THE LAST FIFTEEN MONTHS.
THEY'VE TAKEN ON A DEBT AND
MANY ARE STILL HANGING ON BY A
THREAD. THIS PAST MONTH ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSEHOLDS
REPORTED TO THE CENSUS SLIGHT
OR NO CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY THE NEXT MONTH'S
RENT. A RECENT POLICY LIKE
ANALYSIS ESTIMATES NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS
ARE BEHIND ON RENT. AND AT THE
SAME TIME AS MANY OF US KNOW.
OUR STATE HAS RECEIVED A RECORD
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDS BUT ONLY A SMALL FRACTION
HAS ACTUALLY BEEN RECEIVED BY
STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS. WITH THE AVAILABLE
FUNDING ANY AFFECTION
PROTECTIONS THIS WEEK WOULD BE
FUMBLING ON THE ONE YARD LINE.
IT WOULD BE TRAGIC TO A BIG
FAMILIES ON TO THE STREETS WHEN
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO KEEP
THEM IN THEIR HOMES WITH RENT
REALLY FUNDING. THE WAIVER
PROTECTIONS WE COULD
POTENTIALLY SEE. WOULD ALSO
RESULT IN EXACERBATING
HOMELESSNESS. WITH AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO WE'VE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO AVOID THAT SCENARIO TO KEEP
TENANTS HOUSED AND GET
LANDLORDS INCREASE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. HERE ARE SOME OF THE
MAJOR PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
FIRST IT EXTENDS CURRENT
EVICTION PROTECTIONS FOR THREE
MONTHS UNTIL SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH SO ELIGIBLE TENANTS
AND LANDLORDS CAN RECEIVE
FUNDING. SECOND AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO. EXPANDS PAYMENT RATES FOR
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS.
CURRENTLY LANDLORDS REQUIRE TO
FORGIVE 20% RENTAL DEBT IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE ASSISTANCE FOR
THE REMAINING 80% OR ELSE THE
TENANT ONLY RECEIVE ASSISTANCE
425% THIS BILL ELIMINATES THAT
REQUIREMENT. LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS WOULD SIMPLY RECEIVE A
100% OF RENT OWED. FOR THOSE
THAT ALREADY RECEIVED RENTAL
ASSISTANCE TOP UP PAYMENTS TO
GET 2100% WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY
PROCESSED. LANDLORDS WHOSE
TENANTS HAVE MOVED OUT BUT ARE
STILL- RENTAL PAYMENTS CAN
APPLY AS WELL. AND TENANTS WILL
ALSO BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE DIRECTLY.
THIRD AFTER VISION PROTECTIONS
AND SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH THIS
BILL CREATES A SIX MONTH
BACKSTOPS PROCESS DEPOSIT
FICTIONS ONLY FOR THOSE TENANTS
WHO NEED ADDITIONAL TIME TO
ACCESS RENTAL SYSTEMS. AND
FOURTH COURT RECORDS RELATED TO
EVICTION FOR RENT NONPAYMENT
DURING COVE IT OR THE
CANCELLATION FOR THE COLLECTION
OF COVERT RENTAL DEBT WILL BE
PERMANENTLY SEALED TO AVOID
IMPACTING A PERSON'S LONG TERM
CREDIT. OR ABILITY TO APPLY FOR
FUTURE HOUSING. LIKE PRIOR
COVETED NINETEEN EVICTION
PROTECTION BILLS. THIS BILL IS
BY NO MEANS PERFECT. BUT IF WE
DON'T PASS THIS BILL TODAY WE
COULD SEE A WAVE OF EVICTIONS
AND INCREASED HOMELESSNESS WELL
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF FUNDING
ARE LEFT UNTAPPED. ENDING THESE
PROTECTIONS NOW WOULD SERIOUSLY
UNDERMINE OUR ABILITY TO HELP
OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR CHIU MEMBERS THESE
ARE THE AMENDMENTS ON EIGHT
THIRTY TWO THESE ARE THE
AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED THE BILLS
OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE BILLING CHIEF. THIS IS A
BILL IN CHIEF WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE. AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO.
BY MISTER Q. CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AN ACT
RELATING TO TENNESSEE IN TO
CLEAR THE ABSENCE HERE OF
SIGNIFICANTLY. MISTER CHILL IF
YOU WISH APPARENTLY I'VE
ALREADY MADE THE PRESENTATION
OF THE BILL SO I WILL JUST
DEFER TO MY PRIOR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SIR. MEMBERS WISHING
TO PARTICIPATE IN DEBATE RANGER
MICROPHONES NOW MISTER GIBSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT A
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT THIRTY TWO ALTHOUGH THIS%
BILL AS THE AUTHORS INDICATED
IS NOT THE PERFECT VIDEO. BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY. MEMBERS. EVEN
THOUGH THIS BILL IS NOT A
PERFECT BILL IS CERTAINLY
CERTAINLY IS IN THE RIGHT IN A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOW AS WE SEE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE HOMELESS. AND OF NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN- THIS
PANDEMIC HAS ROCKED PEOPLE
TRAJECTORY. LIKE NO OTHER. LAST
YEAR WE'VE SEEN MANY PEOPLE ON
THE STREETS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
MY CONSTITUENTS ARE SUFFERING
MANY OF YOU KNOW BECAUSE I'VE
SAID IT TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THAT I REPRESENT THE SIX
POOREST DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN. I REPRESENTS. THE SIX
FOUR IS THIS A GOOD STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SECOND
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE IT
FOR THE PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR
HOMES AND CERTAINLY THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
WE CAN HAVE PEOPLE STAYING IN
THEIR HOME THERE'S NO PLACE
LIKE HOME. EXPRESSLY WHEN IT'S
RAINING OUTSIDE PEOPLE NEED
SHELTER PEOPLE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WANT THE GOVERNMENT
THEY CAN DEPEND ON THE
GOVERNMENT IS RESPONSIVE AND
THEY'RE STEPPING UP TO THE
PLATE AND SO I CAN THINK OF NO
BETTER WAY. OF THEM TO SHOW
PEOPLE AND CALIFORNIANS THOSE
WHO ARE HURTING ON GIVING THEM
THE ABILITY TO STAY IN THEIR
HOME. IT'S THEIR ABILITY TO
HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD
THEIR ABILITY TO TURN A CORNER
THEIR ABILITIES THE LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL THEIR
ABILITY TO WEATHER THIS STORM
THAT'S BEFORE US. EVEN THOUGH
WE OPEN UP THE STATE OUR PEOPLE
ARE STILL OPEN IN CLOSE.
QUARTERS BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
SEE THE LIGHT THEY COULD NOT
SEE ALL THE HERE'S THE RAIN AND
THE STORM AND SO THIS IS IN A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AS
I SAID. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE
WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE THOSE
WERE IMPACTED IS TO FIFTH OF A
THIRD OF A SUPPORTER OF THE
PEOPLE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR ON
THAT ARE SUFFERING- ON DUDA'S
PANDEMIC AND WHO'S MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK OUR VOTE. ON
THIS BILL I THANK YOU OFFER TO
WORK EXTREMELY HARD HIM AND HIS
TEAM TO GET THIS BILL BEFORE US
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I
BOTH UNDERSTAND THE BILL. EIGHT
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
MISTER. IF YOU'RE BLOWN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO
WHICH IS A CRUCIAL MEASURE TO
EXTEND THE EVICTION MORATORIUM
AND PROVIDE RENT RELIEF FOR
THOUSANDS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS I
WANT TO THANK. THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE STAFF AND
ESPECIALLY OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO WHO HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO BRING AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO BEFORE US. AND
ENSURE THAT SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES DO NOT
FACE THE ONSLAUGHT OF EVICTIONS.
DURING AUGUST OF LAST YEAR I
ASK THIS BODY TO SUPPORT AB
THREE OH EIGHT EIGHT OUR FIRST
EVICTION MORATORIUM MEASURE TO
PROTECT TENANTS AFFECTED BY A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. AND
EARLIER THIS YEAR I SPOKE IN
SUPPORT OF EXTENDING THE
MORATORIUM BECAUSE WE WERE ON
THE CUSP AT THAT TIME OF
WITNESSING CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND. EVICTION
CASES. AND TODAY I RISE ONCE
AGAIN URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO. UNLIKE
THE LAST TWO MEASURES AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO COMES BEFORE US AT A
CRITICAL JUNCTURE. ON OUR ROAD
TO RECOVERY TODAY CLOSE 260% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE FULLY
VACCINATED. OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IS SLOWLY REOPENING
AND OUR CHILDREN NOW BACK AT
SCHOOL AFTER MONTHS OF REMOTE
LEARNING. WE ARE SEEING
CALIFORNIA BOUNCE BACK BUT FOR
CLOSE TO A MILLION RENTERS
ACROSS OUR STATE BACK TO NORMAL
WILL MEAN AN EVICTION AVALANCHE
IF WE DO NOT PASS AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO IN L. A. COUNTY
ALONE MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN MADE HOMELESS
SINCE THE START OF THE OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC. A RECENT UCLA
STUDY ESTIMATES THAT L. A.
COUNTY CURRENTLY HAS OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNLAWFUL
DETAINER CASES IN THE BACKLOG.
THAT IS OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND MORE FAMILIES THAT
COULD BECOME HOMELESS IF WE DO
NOT EXTEND THE MORATORIUM AND
PROVIDE RENTAL RELIEF AND THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. BELIEVES
THAT IF WE DO NOTHING. A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WILL BE ADDED TO OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION. THERE ALSO
HAVE BEEN MORE AND MORE REPORTS
OF HOUSEHOLDS OPTING TO SELF
AFFECT BECAUSE OF HARASSMENT BY
LANDLORDS AND ILLEGAL LOCKOUTS
MORE FAMILIES ARE CHOOSING TO
LEAVE THEIR APARTMENTS TO AVOID
TAKING ON THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN CRIPPLING CONSUMER DEBT TO
PAY BACK THE RENT OF. THE
MEMBERS YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO WILL HELP
PREVENT AN EVICTION AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IT'S THAT
SIMPLE AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO WILL
EXTEND THE EVICTION MORATORIUM
FOR THREE MONTHS TO KEEP
FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES AND
PROVIDE RENT ASSISTANCE TO
COVER ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. OF
RENTS OWED SAVING BOTH RENTERS
AND SMALL LANDLORDS FROM
FINANCIAL RUIN. THE MEASURE
ALSO REQUIRES PARENTAL CIVIL
CASES FROM COVERT BE MASKED TO
PROTECT TENANTS FROM HAVING
THESE CASES IMPACT THEIR
CONSUMER CREDIT OR TO PREVENT
THEM FROM SEEKING FUTURE
HOUSING. AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO
WILL PROVIDE OUR HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES WITH THE SAFETY NET
SO THAT THEY TOO CAN BOUNCE
BACK FROM THE PANDEMIC AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
MISS DAVIES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S A FULL OVER
THERE. HI MR LACKEYS DESK MISS
DAVIES. OKAY GREAT ALRIGHT
FORGET IT MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE I SUPPORTED THIS
EARLIER FIVE MONTH EXTENSION IN
JANUARY AS EMBODIED IN SB
NINETY ONE BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT
HELD PROMISE OF COMPROMISE TO
HELP TENANTS AND COMPENSATE
SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS THAT
PROMISE HAS NOT BEEN KEPT. FIVE
MONTHS LATER I RECEIVED
HUNDREDS OF TEXAS EMAILS AND
CALLS JUST TODAY I RECEIVED
OVER FIFTY CALLS FROM
FRUSTRATED SMALLRENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO ARE
PLEADING WITH ME THEY WOULD
RATHER HAVE CONTROL THEIR
PROPERTY AND LIVELIHOOD BACK
THEN PUT THEIR FAITH IN NEVER
ENDING EVICTION MORATORIUMS THE
FLOW DISTRIBUTION OF RENTAL
RELIEF MONEY. WE TALK ABOUT
EQUITY IN THIS CHAMBER BUT
WHERE IS THE EQUITY WHEN WE
HAVE REPORTS INCLUDING
STATEMENTS BY THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION'S ATTENDED SCANNING
THE SYSTEM WHEN THEY CAN AFFORD
TO PAY THE IRONY IS THAT THIS
EXTENSION WOULD NOT BE%
NECESSARY IF WE HAD COMPETENT
LEADERSHIP ENSURING THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WE'RE
DISTRIBUTING. RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDS TO TENANTS AND HOUSING
PROVIDERS IN AN EXPEDITED
MANNER IT IS FRUSTRATING THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
NUMEROUS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
NOT QUICKLY DISTRIBUTED TO
THOSE IN NEED ESPECIALLY TO THE
MOM AND POP RENTAL HOUSING
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
RENT PAYMENTS YET STILL PAY THE
MORTGAGE INTEREST TAXES
MAINTENANCE AND OTHER EXPENSES.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE MR MRS BAILEY
FROM SACRAMENTO IN MY DISTRICT
THEY HAVE A RENTER WHO OWES
THEM NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
BACK RENT AND HAVE TOLD THEM
THEY HAVE NO. INTENTION OF
COOPERATING TO PAY IT BACK.
MISTER HILL- OWNS A SMALL MOM
AND POP RENTA FOR AND ORANGE
COUNTY NEW NOT RISKY ANY. NINE
RENT RELIEF LET ALONE RENT
SUBSIDY. HE HAS HAD TO ENTER
MANY FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS THIS
PAST YEAR BECAUSE HE HAS NO
INCOME. AS OF JUNE TWENTY
FOURTH THE STATE HAS SENT OUT
ONLY SIXTY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION THE ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION SHARES. THAT IS
DISTURBING LESS THAN 5%
500-040-0402 APPLICANTS
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS. WHO HAVE
SO FAR APPLIED FOR ONLY HALF OF
THE MONEY. HOW WOULD THIS
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT SIX
BILLION MATTER. FOR A TOTAL OF
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION WHEN THE
FIRST ONE HUNDRED MILLION COULD
NOT EVEN GET OUT THE DOOR.
MEMBERS I WAS WILLING TO
CONTEMPLATE SUPPORTING IF
REPUBLICANS WERE GIVEN A SEAT
AT THE TABLE TO COME UP WITH
THE CHIU COMPROMISED. AFTER WE
PASSED THE BIPARTISAN RELIEF
MEASURE EARLIER THIS YEAR BUT
SADLY THIS BILL WAS DONE BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS I ASKED FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS DAVIES MR
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOOD AFTERNOON SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
TENANTS SO ATTENDANT RIGHTS ACT
THE STATE HAD EVER SEEN IN THE
FORM OF TENANT PROTECTION ACT.
HOWEVER AS CRITICAL AS AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WAS WE
COULD NOT HAVE ANTICIPATED THEN
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC OR
THE SEVERITY OF THE ADDICTION
CRISIS WE WOULD BE FACING NOW
TODAY WE CONTINUE BUILDING ON
THE WORK WE DID WITH AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO TO PROTECT
TENANTS BY PASSING THIS
EVICTION MORATORIUM. ONE IN
THREE HOUSEHOLDS RENT THEIR
HOMES IN MY DISTRICT IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND THAT NUMBER IS
ON THE RISE WITHOUT SUPPORT
MANY OF THESE RENTERS STAND ON
THE PRECIPICE OF THE DICTION
CONTINUED UNEMPLOYMENT AND
POTENTIAL HOMELESSNESS. THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF THINGS IN
PARTICULAR THAT MAKE THIS BILL
SO VERY IMPORTANT WE ALL NEED
ACCESS TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT A GOOD CREDIT SCORE
IS ESSENTIAL TO SECURING A
PLACE TO LIVE THANKFULLY THIS
BILL PROTECTS TENANTS CREDIT BY
PERMANENTLY MAKE IT MASKING
COURT RECORDS RELATED TO
EVICTIONS FOR NON PAYMENT OF
RENT DURING THE PANDEMIC AND TO
ACTIONS TO RECOVER RENTAL DEBT.
THIS MEANS THESE RECORDS WILL
BE OFF LIMITS TO CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCIES THIS WILL
HELP PROTECT TENANTS THEIR
CREDIT AND WILL PROTECT OR HELP
ENSURE THAT THEY WON'T BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN THE
FUTURE FOR THE STRUGGLES THEY
FACED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
WHAT'S MORE BY PROVIDING
LANDLORDS WITH 1100% OF THE
RENTAL DEBT OWED. WE WILL NOT
ONLY BE HELPING OUR SMALL
LANDLORDS BUT WE WILL BE
HELPING MORE TENANTS RECEIVE
THE FUNDING THEY NEED TO KEEP A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS THE STATE
WILL BE REELING WILL CONTINUE
AND BE REELING FROM IMPACTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC FOR
YEARS TO COME. WETHERBY FROM
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP JOB LOSSES OR
FOR MANY THE LOSS OF EVEN LOVED
ONES. ONE OF THE FIRST STEPS WE
NEED TO TAKE TOWARDS RECOVERY
IS PROTECTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CONSTITUENTS FROM
FURTHER HARDSHIP BY EVICTION.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE TOOLS TO
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET AND THAT
MEANS HOUSING AND STRONG
CREDIT. THESE PROTECTIONS ARE
NECESSARY FOR PRESERVING OUR
COMMUNITIES PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND REBUILDING OUR
WORKFORCES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GRAYSON. MISTER FLORIDA MEMBERS
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE
RESPECT YOUR MICROPHONES NOW MR
FOR. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. BUT I DID I
JUST TALK TO THEIR THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE REITERATE THAT
OUT OF THIS MONEY RIGHT NOW IS
ROUGHLY ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO
THIS PROGRAM. ONLY SIXTY ONE
MILLION OF THAT. HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN PUSHED OUT THE DOOR. AND I
TALKED ABOUT THAT I THINK IS
GONNA DRESS IT IN HIS CLOTHES
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW. THE
OVERSIGHT. HOW THIS IS GOING TO
BE PUSHED OUT. IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO WE CAN GET IT TO THE
MEN. AND THE WOMEN AND THE
FAMILIES THAT SO DESPERATELY
NEED THIS MONEY SO. ARE YOU
CLOSE TAKE IT IN YOUR CLOSE I'D
PREVIOUSLY MUCH. THANK YOU MR
FLORA MISS CORREO. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
THREE TWO I REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT IS SPLIT BY A
HIGHWAY OR FREEWAY THE ONE TEN
FREEWAY ON ONE SIDE I HAVE A
VERY AFFLUENT COMMUNITY IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND ON THE
OTHER SIDE I HAVE
UNINCORPORATED EAST LOS ANGELES
WHICH IS 20% BELOW THE NATIONAL
POVERTY LINE THIS IS A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN HIT THE
HARDEST BY COVERT. WHEN WE
PASSED THE ORIGINAL BILL TO
EXTEND THE EVICTION MORATORIUM
A WE WERE AT A STATE WIDE DEATH
TOLL OF THIRTY THOUSAND BECAUSE
OF COLD IT LET'S NOT FORGET THE
REASON WHY WE ARE HERE THE
REASON THAT WHY WE ARE
EXTENDING THIS IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE ALL LIVED SURVIVED AND ARE
DOING THE VERY BEST WE CAN AMID
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC WORD THE
IMPACT TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
HAS BEEN REAL AND DEVASTATING
TO DATE MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES TO COVERT NINETEEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALONE
WORKERS HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
STUDENTS HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
GO TO SCHOOL AT THE RATE THAT
THEY WERE GOING BEFORE KIDS
HAVE GONE HUNGRY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE
LUNCHES AT SCHOOL. PARENTS
ACROSS THE STATE AND ACROSS THE
NATION HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
WITH PAYING RENT. PAYING THEIR
UTILITIES AND SIMPLY TRYING TO
SURVIVE. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO DO RIGHT BY SO MANY WHO
DESERVE AND ARE DESERVING OF
OUR HELP AND OUR EIGHT. AND I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACTUALLY THINK THE LANDLORDS
WHO TOOK THE INITIAL THE
INITIAL PROGRAM THAT WE HAD
WHICH WAS A 20% FORGIVENESS TO
RENTERS. AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
WITH THIS NEW PROPOSAL
CURRENTLY IN PROCESS THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR THE 20%
DIFFERENCE SO THAT THAT THEY
ARE ALSO MADE WHOLE. THIS IS
1100% RENT RELIEF AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU LOOK AT
THE DETAILS AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE CAN'T
DO BOTH. AND I'VE BEEN SAYING
THAT ALL ALONG WE CAN HELP
LANDLORDS ENSURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS ON HOW
TO APPLY FOR THE FUNDING AND
YES IT IS TAKING LONG AND I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO. THANK
ALL OF THE STATE EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE TRYING THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITIES WHILE ALSO LIVING
THROUGH A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THEMSELVES TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS WORK AND THAT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS IS AS
SEAMLESS AS POSSIBLY CAN BE AND
WE ALL KNOW. THERE ARE
TECHNOLOGICAL PROBLEMS WITH THE
WAY IN WHICH CALIFORNIA
TECHNOLOGY AND SYSTEMS WORK
THAT WE WILL ALSO GET TO
ADDRESS BUT IT WON'T BE
ADDRESSED TODAY AND IT WILL BE
ADDRESSED AND FIXED TOMORROW
IT'S GOING TO TAKE. TIME WE
HAVE DONE OVERSIGHT THE BUDGETS
OF FOUR WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THE OVERSIGHT NECESSARY I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION TO
TENANTS INTO RENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO
THANK OUR SPEAKER AND THE
LEADERSHIP FOR THEIR DEDICATION
AND ASSOCIATIONS AND FIGHTING
FOR WORKING CLASS FAMILIES
ACROSS OUR STATE TO ENSURE THAT
THIS FUNDING THAT THESE MONIES
ACTUALLY GO TO THE MOST TO THE
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED. AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF TECHNOLOGY UNLOCK A
BRAND OF BROADBAND A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OR EVEN LANGUAGE
COMPETENCY. SEVERAL COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE NOT NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING. HAVE LACKED THE
ACCESS TO ACTUALLY RECEIVE
THESE FUNDS LATINOS ARE ONE OF
THE MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY
APPLY OR RECEIVE THESE MONIES
AND WE GET TO WORK ON THAT AS
WELL. AND THAT IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PIECE CONSIDERING WHO
HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS
PANDEMIC. SO AGAIN THIS IS A
CRITICAL STEP FORWARD. WE ARE
MAKING LANDLORDS 1100% WHOLE WE
ARE ENSURING THAT RENTERS ARE
ABLE TO STAY HOME AND CONTINUE
TO BE SAFE WE ARE NOT DONE WITH
COBIT THIS IS STILL AN ONGOING
PANDEMIC. BUT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIGURE IT OUT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
PEOPLE WHICH ULTIMATELY AT THE
END OF THE DAY. IS OUR JOB.
RIGHT NOW ALL. LET ME- SHARE A
COUPLE OF JUST PIZZA UP BITS OF
INFORMATION HERE. IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS OWED AN AVERAGE OF
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN BACK
RENT NOW THERE ARE NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS THAT- AN
AVERAGE OF CLOSE TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN BACK RENT.
WE CAN HELP AND THIS IS A STEP
FORWARD TO DO SO I WOULD HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE THAT YOU HELP THE
PEOPLE YOUR CONSTITUENTS OF
YOUR DISTRICTS STAY HOME STAY
SAFE NOT GET EVICTED AND
CONTINUE TO DO THE VERY BEST
THAT THEY CAN FOR THEMSELVES
AND FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND I
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON
AB EIGHT THREE TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS CARILLO. ISRAEL'S
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I TO JOIN. AND
RISING SUPPORT AS A JOINT
AUTHORED THIS VITAL LEGISLATION.
TODAY AS WE CONSIDER THIS
LEGISLATION WE LOOK AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATE AND
WE SEE THE PROGRESS THAT RE
OPENING OUR ECONOMY GETTING
VACCINES INTO ARMS AND
RETURNING TO BE WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. BUT AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM EAST LA. L. STE HOW DID WE
GET HERE WE CANNOT FORGET HOW
WE GOT TO THIS MOMENT. A
WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC THAT HAS
CLAIMED THE LIVES OF OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. M. SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DEATHS
NATIONWIDE REQUIRED THAT WE
STAY AT HOME RESULTING IN
WORKERS LOSING THEIR JOBS. AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
UNABLE TO PAY THEIR RENT. TODAY
WE GET A CHANCE TO MAKE IT
RIGHT. TO PROVIDE CONTINUED
RELIEF TO THOSE THAT FACE THIS
HARDSHIP THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. TODAY WE GET A
CHANCE TO VOTE ON THIS BILL TO
MAKE SURE THE TENANTS CAN STAY
IN THEIR HOMES. AND THAT
LANDLORDS CAN BE PAID AND MADE
WHOLE. THIS IS A TYPE OF WIN
WIN LEGISLATION THAT WE CAN ALL
BE PROUD OF. I WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBER FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
FOR HIS TIRELESS EFFORTS ON
THIS ISSUE. I WANT TO THANK
SPEAKER RENDON FOR HIS WORK AND
FOR HIS TEAM'S WORK TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN AND I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES AND STAKEHOLDERS.
FOR THEIR INPUT. AND FEEDBACK
THAT HELPED US ARRIVE AT THIS
MOMENT WITH THIS I ASKED WE ALL
SUPPORT. AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISS REYES THANK YOU
MEMBERS. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION. MR
CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ARE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL AND I WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT BEEN RAISED. FIRST OF ALL-
WE'VE HEARD- PARTICULARLY
RECENT WEEKS ABOUT THE CONCERN
OF SOME. WHO ALLEGEDLY MIGHT
BEGIN IN THE SYSTEM WHO CAN
AFFORD TO PAY BUT OUR- LET ME
SAY A FEW THINGS ABOUT THAT
FIRST. THE STATISTICS DON'T
BEAR THAT OUT THE DAY THAT WE
HAVE SEEN. OUR WHO HAS NO PAID.
OF THE VA'S MAJORITY THESE AND
OF. ARE WHO CALL. FOR THE
FINANCIALS TO THAT WE OF FOR.
BUT IF IT TURNS OUT THAT THERE
ARE THOSE IN. THIS IS A TOPIC
THAT WE'VE ADDRESSED. IN
EXCRUCIATING DETAIL IN THE BILL
THAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO VOTE ON
FIRST. AS IT'S BEEN THE CASE IN
RECENT MONTHS. IF A TENANT.
DECLARES THAT THEY'RE ON ABLE
TO PAY THEY HAVE TO A TEXAS
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY. THEY
HAVE TO SIGN THAT THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO COULD BE
PROSECUTED FOR FRAUD IF THEY
MISTAKE. SECONDLY EVERY TENANTS
IF THEY DON'T PAY RENT THERE
WILL BE WILL- A 100% A
MISPRINT. THIS BILL DOES NOT
FORGIVE THAT. AND UNDER THE
PRIOR EVICTION PROTECTION LAWS
IN THE PAST WE'VE MADE IT MUCH
EASIER. AND MUCH MORE
INEXPENSIVE FOR LANDLORDS TO
RECOVER THAT MISSING RIGHT
ALLOWING THE ALERTS TO USE A
SMALL CLAIMS PROCESS REGARDLESS
OF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
REQUESTED OR THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMS BROUGHT. AND IF THE
TENANT HAS UNPAID RENTAL DATA
ANALYST SUSAN. THAT LEONARD
WILL GET A MONEY JUDGMENT FOR
THE AMOUNT. ONCE THAT JUDGMENT
IS ISSUED A TENANTS WAGES COULD
BE GARNISHED AND FUNDS
WITHDRAWN FROM THEIR BANK
ACCOUNTS. I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW IF
A TENANT LEAVES IN THE DEAD OF
NIGHT. LANDLORDS WILL GET PAID
WELL UNDER THIS BILL. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE LANDLORD
ADVOCATES LANDLORDS CAN APPLY
TO GET PAID DIRECTLY A LANDLORD
CAN INITIATE THE APPLICATION. I
KNOW WE'VE HEARD FROM ANOTHER
COLLEAGUES WHO IS ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
OVERSIGHT THERE IS. ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE'VE HAD SLOW
DISBURSEMENT OF RENTAL FUNDS
THUS FAR LET ME SAY I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYONE ON THIS
CHAMBER. WHO HAS NOT BEEN
FRUSTRATED AT HOW LONG IT'S
TAKEN TO GET THIS MONEY OUT.
BUT THERE ARE MANY REASONS FOR
THE SLOW DISBURSEMENT THUS FAR.
THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM. IT WAS
JUST SET UP AT THE STATE LEVEL
A FEW MONTHS AGO WHEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVELS. IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS THEY'VE JUST
STARTED IN THE LAST MONTH TO
GET MONEY OUT. THEY'RE BEEN
VERY COMPLICATED AND CHANGING
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS. THE
ADMINISTRATION THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN HAMPERED BY
CHALLENGES IN EDUCATING.
MILLIONS OF TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS. LANGUAGE ACCESS
DIGITAL DIVIDES. AS WELL AS- A
COMPLICATED APPLICATION AND
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS.
THAT HAVE JUST IN THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS BEEN STREAMLINED.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF WORK TO
PROP THIS UP. AND IT IS TRUE
THAT ONLY SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN PAID OUT THUS
FAR BUT I WILL JUST KNOW
COMPARED TO THAT SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
HAVE BEEN REQUESTED THESE ARE
THE APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
PENDING THUS FAR. AND WE KNOW
MANY MANY MORE APPLICATIONS ARE
COMING IN. WE'VE ALSO HEARD THE
SUGGESTION THAT BECAUSE AN
EVICTION CLIFF HAS NOT YET
OCCURRED. THAT SUGGESTS ONE
WILL NOT OCCUR IN THE FUTURE. I
WOULD SUGGEST IT'S BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD THESE PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE SINCE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN.
THAT WE PREVENTED THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO. THAT IS A GOOD
THING. WE NEED NOT GET A TASTE
OF DISASTER BEFORE WE TRY TO
PREVENT THE DISASTER. LET ME
JUST CLOSE BY THANKING SO MANY
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION I WANT TO THANK
OUR SPEAKER. MAJORITY LEADER
PARTICULAR WANT TO THANK OUR
STAFF FROM THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
THE HOUSING AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES BUT- ALSO SO MANY OF
YOU I'VE HAD SO MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH COLLEAGUES.
YOU HAVE HELPED TO SHAPE THIS
BILL ALONG WITH THE MANY
STICKLES OR BEEN A PART OF IT.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS HOUSED.
WE HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION TO
DO SO AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR CHIU. AND
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. THOSE ARE ALL TIED
UP HIGHS FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS.
NINE ON THE URGENCY HIGHS FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE ON THE MEASURE
THAT BILL PASSES.
WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE. ISRAEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULES SIXTY THREE IN NINETY SIX
TO WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING BILLS
FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
PLACE THEM ON THIRD READING TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE THEM UP FOR PASSAGE TODAY.
MR FLOOR FOR WHAT PURPOSE
HOLDEN ELSE CONSENT AS FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE. MISTER FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING MEMBERS THIS IS
PROCEDURAL MS RAYOS MOVES. AND
MR TANG SECONDS. ON THE ROLE
SUSPENSION. CORKERY THE BILL'S.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY NINE TO
NUMBER ONE THIRTY NINE TO
NUMBER ONE FOR YOU TO SET UP A
ONE FORTY SIX AND A ONE FORTY
SEVEN SAID OVER ONE FIFTY TWO
INTO NUMBER ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
IS RAMOS IS ASKING FOR AN
ONLINE VOTE MISTER FLORA. I
KNOW. MS RADIUS IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MISTER FLOOR UNTIL
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE AS
FIFTY ONE KNOWS NINETEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS
IS SB. ONE FIFTY TWO. KERKORIAN
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY TWO BY
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS MAKING
APPROPRIATION ARE FOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BEVERLY TO
THE BUDGET MISTER KING EMAIL
PRINT IMAGE SPEAKER I'M HONORED
TO PRESENT OUR BUDGET TRAILER
BILL FOR OUR FIRST ONE IS S. B.
ONE FIFTY TWO PERTAINING TO
ELECTIONS THE BILL CONTAINS
NECESSARY CLARIFICATIONS FOR
THE RECALL ELECTION PROCESS IS
SPECIFIED THAT THE RECALL
ELECTION WILL BE A REGULAR
ELECTION PROVIDE SPECIFIC
DIRECTIONS TO COUNTY. ON THE
NUMBER OF VOTING CENTERS THAT
MUST BE OPEN BASED ON
POPULATION THE BILL MAINTAINS
THE ADDITIONAL VOTER ACCESS
BECAUSE ACTIVELY APPROVED PRIOR
TO THE NOVEMBER GENERAL
ELECTION THE CAREFULLY BALANCES
THE COST COUNTIES WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE TO FIND OUT OF
THEIR ALREADY STRETCHED THIN
BUDGETS TO THAT IN THE BILL
PROVIDES THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE SUPPORT COUNTIES IN THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ELECTION. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR A VOTE ON
SB ONE FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISS TANK MR FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ONE FIFTY TWO OUR
ELECTORAL SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO
BROUGHT TO PROMOTE DEMOCRACY
TRUST AND TRANSPARENCY THIS
BILL DOES THE EXACT OPPOSITE IT
IS ANOTHER EFFORT TO MANIPULATE
THE TIMING OF AN ELECTION IS AN
ATTEMPT TO PUT A THUMB ON THE
SCALE. TO TRY TO OBTAIN A
PARTISAN OUTCOME FOR ONE SIDE.
WE NEED A PAUSE AND REEVALUATE
THE ACTIONS THIS BILL IS
TAKING. THIS IS NOT A PATH WE
SHOULD BE GOING DOWN. MOREOVER
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
HAS RECENTLY BEEN INVOLVED IN A
CONTROVERSY OF HIRING A PERSON
CAMPAIGN FIRM TO CONDUCT ITS
OUTREACH EFFORTS. THERE ARE NO
ASSURANCES IN THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT CONTRACTS ARE GIVEN
SOME NONPARTISAN FIRMS WHICH
OUTREACH EFFORTS ARE TRULY DONE
IN A NON PARTISAN MANNER. WITH
NONPARTISAN MESSAGES OVER ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SIGNED A
RECALL PETITION. OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES THEM THAT
OPTION. VERY AND MANY MORE WILL
SHOW UP AND VOTE WHENEVER THE
ELECTION IS SET. BUT THE
MESSAGES SENT WITH THIS BILL.
PROVES THE PUBLIC'S FRUSTRATION
THAT POLITICIANS WOULD DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN DO TO STAY IN
POWER. MOVING THE GOALPOSTS IS
ALSO UNFAIR TO OUR COUNTY
CLERKS AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
WILL BE FORCED TO BEAR EVEN
MORE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
WELL THISBILL COMPLETELY
BYPASSES LEGISLATIVE REVIEW.
THE ACTIONS WE ARE DEBATING
TODAY. ONLY FURTHER ERODES
PUBLIC TRUST WE SHOULD NOT GO
DOWN THIS PATH MEMBERS I
STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU MR FONG MR KILEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE. WE SHOULD BE VOTING
IN THE RECALL RIGHT NOW THE
ONLY REASON THEY WERE NOT IS
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED A NEW
LAW A FEW YEARS AGO OVERHAULING
THE RECALL PROCESS TO MAKE IT
TAKE A LOT LONGER. NOW EVERYONE
KNEW AT THE TIME THAT IT WAS A
SHAM AND IT WAS DESIGNED SOLELY
TO TRY TO SAVE A SITTING STATE
SENATOR JOSH NEWMAN WHO WAS
THEN FACING. A RECALL. NOW I
WILL SAY THIS ABOUT SENATOR
NEWMAN. TO HIS CREDIT. AT THE
TIME HE DECLINED TO BE DIRECTLY
COMPLICIT. IN THE SCHEME BEING
PERPETRATED ON HIS BEHALF IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHEN TAT BILL
WAS UNDER CONSIDERATION. HE
ROSE ON THE FOR THE SENATE AND
SAID THIS HE SAID NOW LET ME
POINT OUT. FOR THE AVOIDANCE OF
DOUBT HERE THAT I AM NOTTHE
AUTHOR OF THESE PROVISIONS NOR
DID I REQUEST THEIR INCLUSION.
AND I WILL BE OF STAINING FROM
VOTING ON THIS MEASURE TODAY.
SENATOR NEWMAN SEEM TO
RECOGNIZE THAT HE SHOULD NOT BE
A JUDGE. IN HIS OWN BECAUSE
THAT IF THE DIRTY DEED WAS TO
BE DONE BUT AT LEAST HIS
FINGERPRINTS SHOULDN'T BE ON IT.
THAT BARE MINIMUM LEVEL OF
DECENCY. EXHIBITED BY SENATOR
JOSH NEWMAN IS WAY TOO MUCH TO
ASK. OF GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM.
THIS TRAILER BILL. WAS
NEGOTIATED BY HIS ADMIN. A PAIR
HIS OWN CAMP HOW TO IN IT AS
THEY REFUSE MULTIPLE REQUESTS
COMMENT BY THE S. PRESS. AND
THE WILL ONLY TAKE A FACT WHEN
GOVERNOR SIGNS IT. SO WE HAVE
THE UNPRECEDENTED CIRCUMSTANCE.
WHERE GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM.
WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN WILL
BE CHANGING CALIFORNIA LAW. IN
ORDER TO TRY TO BEAT BACK HIS
OWN RECALL. MISTER NAZARIAN
CEDAR POINT ORDER CAN WE JUST
STICK TO THE MERITS OF WHAT
WE'RE HERE TO VOTE ON AND NOT
JUST GO ON AND ON AND ON MISTER
SPEAKER. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT. MISTER NAZARIAN OF THE
POINT OF ORDER. NOW WILL TAKE A
DO BELIEVE THIS KELLY SPEAKING
TO. THE MEASURE BEFORE US BUT
MR KILEY PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS CONFINED TO. THE
ELECTIONS THAT TRAILER BILL.
BEFORE THE BODY. THIS IS- YOU
MAY YOU MAY HAVE MISSED SOME
PARTS BUT IT'S BECOMING OVERLY
POLITICAL AND IT'S ALL ABOUT.
SEEING AS MANY THINGS AS
NEGATIVE AS POSSIBLE ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR RIGHT NOW I DON'T WANT
THE FLOOR TO BE MISUSED THAT
WAY. THANK YOU MRS ERIN.
COMMUNISTS NOTED MR KILEY MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU FOR DENYING
THAT POINT OF ORDER MISTER
SPEAKER WE KNOW THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAIN SPOKESMAN ON
THE ISSUE THE CENTER FOR ORINDA
HAS SAID SO DIRECTLY HE SAID
BEST OPPORTUNITY TO BEAT THIS
RECKLESS RECALL OF GAVIN
NEWSOM. IS TO HAVE AN EARLY
ELECTION. HE SAID GAVIN NEWSOM
SHOULD FIGHT THE BATTLE ON HIS
TERMS. HE SAID HE SHOULD STRIKE
WHILE HIS FAVORABLES ARE STRONG
ENOUGH. THE CENTER WENT ON
TELEVISION AND SAID IN MY
CALCULATION THERE'S A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS OUT THERE THAT COULD
CHANGE THE POSITIVE ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE'VE SEEN ON HIS BEHALF.
HE CONTINUED THAT DRIVES MY
POLITICAL ADVICE THE NO ACTION
SOONER UNDER THE LAW WOULD BE A
BETTER CIRCUMSTANCE FOR. BUT
THE SENATOR GOT AHEAD OF
HIMSELF. BECAUSE IT TURNS OUT
THAT THE LAW THAT IS THE
CORRUPT ONE PASSED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DIDN'T ALLOW FOR THE
ELECTION TO HAPPEN AS EARLY AS
HE SUGGESTING. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM SAID NO PROBLEM
WE'LL JUST CHANGE THE LAW IN
ORDER TO HAVE THE ELECTION WHEN
WE THINK IT'LL GIVE US THE BEST
CHANCE. TO WIN. IT IS NOT
HYPERBOLE TO SAY THIS IS
QUALITATIVELY THE SAME THING
THAT HAPPENS IN CORRUPT SHAM
DEMOCRACIES THE WORLD OVER.
THOSE IN POWER USED THEIR POWER
TO MAKE SURE THEY DON'T LOSE
THEIR POWER. THEIR
INTERNATIONAL ELECTION
OBSERVERS ORGANIZATIONS
SPECIFICALLY DEVOTED TO
FERRETING OUT THIS TYPE OF ****
CONNERY FOR EXAMPLE THE UNITED
STATES CENTER ON HUMAN RIGHTS
IN ITS GUIDELINES SAYS THAT
EACH TIME ALEXION'S ARE
SCHEDULED. THE DATE SET OUT IN
THE ELECTORAL CALENDAR FOR EACH
PHASE OF THE PROCESS MUST ALLOW
ADEQUATE TIME FOR EFFECTIVE
CAMPAIGNING AND PUBLIC
INFORMATION EFFORTS FOR VOTERS
TO INFORM THEMSELVES AND FOR
THE NECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE
LEGAL TRAINING AND LOGISTIC
ARRANGEMENTS TO BE MADE. THE AS
ELECTORAL KNOWLEDGE NETWORK
SAYS THAT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE MECHANISMS OF THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM B. AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE AND KNOWN TO BOTH
VOTERS AND POLITICAL PARTIES
AND CANDIDATES WELL IN ADVANCE
IN ORDER TO AVOID CONFUSION.
AND DISTRUST IN THE RESULTS
THEY PRODUCE AND ELECTIONS. THE
EUROPEAN COMMISSION FOR
DEMOCRACY THROUGH ALL STATE
DISTINGUISHES COUNTRIES WHERE
THE ELECTORAL FRAMEWORK IS
STABLE THE NECESSARY AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED WELL AHEAD OF THE
NEXT ELECTION FROM OTHER STATES
WERE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
ELECTION LEGISLATION OCCUR
FREQUENTLY IN LATE. AND IN SOME
CASES A FEW MONTHS PRIOR TO
ELECTIONS IN A HASTY AND NON
INCLUSIVE WAY. BUT REALLY THIS
APPEAL. TO INTERNATIONAL HUMAN
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS IS
UNNECESSARY EVERY CHILD KNOWS
THE WORD FOR CHANGING THE RULES
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GAME
THIRTY SECONDS MR CRAP IT'S
CHEATING. AND THE CONCLUSION IS
INESCAPABLE THE GAVIN NEWSOM IS
CHEATING IN THE RECALL IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS HIS WILLING
ACCOMPLICE. NOW WE DON'T KNOW
OF THIS SCHEME WILL WORK. BUT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEING AN
EXTRAORDINARY CITIZENS MOVEMENT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE FIGHTING THE
ACTOR AND THE ABJECT CORRUPTION
OF THIS CAPITAL. AND WHEN YOUR
RESPONSE IS TO BE EVEN MORE
CORRUPT IT'S NOT A SUSTAINABLE
STRATEGY BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY I AM CONFIDENT THAT THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE AND THE
STRENGTH OF OUR CIVIC
INSTITUTIONS WILL WIN OUT IN
THIS ERA OF DECLINE AND FAILURE
WILL BE REVERSED. AND A NEW ERA
OF DECENCY AND INTEGRITY AND
SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA CAN BEGIN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED TO THE
LEGISLATION. THAT IS BEFORE THE
BODY. THESE ARE MR SAY OUR TOES
AMENDMENTS MR SAY ARE TELL ON
THE MEMONS. YOU MISTER CORCORAN
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY TWO WITH.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR HEARING
MY AMENDMENTS THESE AMENDMENTS
WOULD SIMPLY RECOGNIZE WHAT THE
VOTERS HAVE DEMONSTRATED AND
WHAT THEY SIMPLY EXPECT IS
THERE RIGHT. THE DELAYS PLACED
ON RECALLS BY S. B. ONE
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN STAND AGAINST THE
VERY PRINCIPLE OF THE VOTERS.
SO WHILE THESE AMENDMENTS
REMOVED THE SAME HURDLES PLACED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
THESE AENDMENTS TO ALSO SAVE
THE PUBLIC MONEY IN THIS RECALL
ELECTION. THE AMENDMENT SAVES
THE STATE OVER TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. AND FUNDS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AN
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT TO OFFSET
COSTS INCURRED FOR THIS RECALL
IT IS FOR THOSE REASONS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS AMENDMENT. MISS
REYES. I WOULD LIKE THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
ISRAEL'S BELLS ALLAY THOSE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE SECOND
BY MISTER CHOW. SECOND BY MISS
BARRICADE HAND. MEMBERS THIS IS
PROCEDURAL DELAY THE MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALREADY PRESIDENT VOTING
IS THE THRESHOLD MISS RADIANCE
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER C. R. TELL AND NOW MISS
REYES ASKED FOR AND I HAVE A-
ON NINETY MINUTES ON THE TABLE.
MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING.
CLERK WILL CULTURAL AS FIFTY
ONE KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE MEMBERS
ARE LAID ON THE TABLE WE'LL
RETURN TO THE BILL IN CHIEF. DR
CHIU YOUR RECOGNIZE SUCH.
PARVIN DR CHOI MISSPOKE DR CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS I RISE
IN OPPOSITION- ALL OF OUR SB
ONE FIFTY TWO. WHEN WE SET UP
ALL REGULATIONS SO ALL ALL- WE
INTEND TO APPLY IT TO OUR
UNIVERSE ON. WHY THIS A
PARTICULAR BILL RELATED TO. A
CURRENTLY ON GOING OUT RECALL
SPECIAL ELECTION. IN THIS BILL
AMONG OTHER THINGS SO
SPECIFICALLY I ASK YOU TO
CHANGE THE VOTING PROCEDURES.
STE SHASTA SPECIFIC LAW TO THIS
RECALL ELECTION CONDUCTED A
PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST OF. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TOOL REQUIRING
LESS CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOOD THE
POLLING PLACES. AND THE MORE
DAYS SO TOOK COUNT OF BALLOTS.
AND THEN ALSO SICKENING TO
MODIFY AND THEN ACCELERATE THE
RECALL BY WAVERING RECENTLY
ENACTED THE REQUIREMENTS SO FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW
ELECTION. SO WHEN THE NEXT
ELECTION COMES AROUND ORGANON
MODIFY AGAIN. FOR EVERY
ELECTION WE NOW APPLY YEAH
DIFFERENT RULERS I DON'T THINK
GOD THIS IS SO. PROCEDURALLY
WHY MORALLY RIGHT I'LL PULL
IDEA ASK EVERYONE TO VOTE NO TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. MISTER CHANG YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THIS BILL IS ABOUT DEMOCRACY
IT'S ABOUT ENSURING THAT AS
MANY PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN AN ELECTION TO
PARTICIPATE THAT IT'S DONE IN A
WAY THAT MAKES IT AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE FOR EVERY VOTER WHO
MAY HAVE AN OPINION ALL OR MAY
WANT TO CAST THEIR BALLOT IN
THIS RECALL ELECTION PROCESS.
WILL BE ABLE TO BUT IN ADDITION
IT ALSO ENSURES THAT THIS
RECALL ELECTION HAPPENS AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE IF YOU HEAR ABOUT
THE PETITIONERS THEY WOULD HAVE
LIKE THIS TO HAPPEN YESTERDAY.
WITHOUT WITH ANY MORE
ADDITIONAL HAYES WE MIGHT AS
WELL WAIT TILL NOVEMBER OF NEXT
YEAR WHEN THERE IS A GENERAL
ELECTION TO ACTUALLY. DO THIS
THIS OF THIS ELECTION AGAIN
THIS BILL ACTUALLY IS FOR THE
COLLECTION HAPPENS. WEEKLY AS
POSSIBLE WHICH- HI MY BUT MY
BELIEF IS THAT'S WHT THE
RECALL WAS ABOUT WAS TRYING TO
HAVE THE SELECTION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. BUT ALSO ENSURING
THAT AS MANY CALIFORNIANS WANT
TO PARTICIPATE. CAN PARTICIPATE
IN THE SELECTION WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
FOR STAYING WITH THAT CLICK
LIBERAL. CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND OF A. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ADVOCATES. CLERK WILL.
CULTURAL TIE THAT LASTED THREE
KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES WITHOUT OBJECTION MEDIA
TRANSMETAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
SOME CONCURRENCE ITEMS AT THIS
TIME. THIS IS THE CONCURRENCE
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
A. B. THREE ZERO TWO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AND ACTIVE
IN THE TRANSPORTATION. MR WARD
EMAIL OPEN SOURCE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH TWO WOULD ALLOW THE
SAN DIEGO METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
SYSTEM TO ENTER INTO CONTRACTS
TO REGULATE FOR HIGHER VEHICLE
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES FOR THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN ANY CITY
WITHIN THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
THIS BILL PASSED OUT ON A
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS VOTE IN
THE ASSEMBLY THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THE SENATE WERE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK GOODNESS FOR
SEEING NO DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE.
ON THE ADAM CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL. RESEARCHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL THE TIME
BUT I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN PASS RETAIN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETEEN. AB SEVEN
ONE TWO BY MISS CALDERON
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON IMMACULATELY TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS THIS CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVEN TWELVE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE OF SENATE
AMENDMENTS SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDED THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE AS A
RECIPIENT OF THE REVIEW REPORT
TO BE CONDUCTED BY L. A.
COUNTY. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS CALDERON. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
TECOLUTLA. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
RUSSIA CHINA I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY AB SEVEN FORTY TWO.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
IS TAXATION AND IN MAKING A
PROVISIONAL FOR. MISTER
CALDERON YOU MAY GET A BIT.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SEVEN FORTY TWO IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE OF SENATE
AMENDMENTS SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDED TECHNICAL CHANGES FROM
CDSS AND CO AUTHORS. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTE. THANKS CALDERON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLICK
LIBERAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED ABOUT.
WELL CLOSER ROLE THAILAND I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
ADMINISTERED SHALL MISTER CHAI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER AS SPEAK TO
BRADFORD FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
FIFTY TWO S. B. TWO SEVENTY TWO
LAYER FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT ROUTE SIXTY TWO A- THE
FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO HEAR THE FOLLOWING
BILLS DURING THEIR RESCHEDULE
HEARING ON TUESDAY. JUNE TWENTY
NINE. SB TWO THIRTY NINE S.
SENATE BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTES COMMITTEE. SB FOUR
NINETY SEVEN THE MALL. SB TWO
EIGHTEEN JONES SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT JONES S. B. TWO SIXTY
NINE PORTANTINO SB FIVE THIRTY
THIRTY ONE MAJKOWSKI SB THREE
SIXTY WELL. THEY WERE SHOPPING
FOR FLORIDA YOU MISTER SPEAKER
WITH HOLDING OUT CONSENT
NATURAL COLOR MISTER FLORES
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
MR CHILD MOVES AND MISTER WARD
SECONDS ON THE RULES SUSPENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. CARCLUB THE ROLE. SURE
SHOWERS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER FLORIDA IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE MISTER CHOW IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MR FLORA
NOW.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY SEVEN DOES
NINETEEN. THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. N. MISTER SHALL YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
GRANT RECONSIDERATION ON ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
GONZALEZ AND MOVED THE BILL TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED ON AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
OF THE CLERK WILL KNOW THAT THE
BILL HAS NOW MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. AND FINALLY
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX TO
ALLOW THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE STERN FOR THEIR
HEARING ON JULY SEVENTH PENDING
RE REFER ALL FROM THE UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT REQUEST IS
GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE LOTS
OF BUSINESS REMAINING BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY BUT AT THIS TIME
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
INSURANCE IN MEMORY AND AS SUCH
MEMBERS I'D ASK THAT YOU TAKE
ANY CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT
THIS TIME. THEY GIVE YOU
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES AGAIN QUORUM CALL IS
IN PLACE WE HAVE LOTS OF
BUSINESS REMAINING THIS
AFTERNOON. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE HAD ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY AT THIS TIME PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE-FLOOR MEMBERS. I'D ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS. IN
MEMORY. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION.
TO SPEAK ON THAT ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE TO
JOURNAL MEMORY OF ELLSWORTH
EVERT GROVES. PASSED AWAY ON
JUNE THIRTEENTH OF THIS YEAR.
ELLSWORTH HAS KNOWN TO HIS
FRIENDS AS ELES HE LIVED AND
TRAVELED ALL OVER THE UNITED
STATES. BUT THANKFULLY HE ENDED
UP IN THE ANTELOPE VALLEY. HE
BEGAN HIS CAREER IN THE US NAVY
AND SERVED DURING THE KOREAN
WAR. IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR. HE
WORKED AS A CORRECTIONS OFFICER
AT THE CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HE WAS
SELECTED TO BE A CHP OFFICER.
LATER PROMOTING TO CAPTAIN.
IT'S WORTHY TO NOTE THAT THE
ALSO GRADUATED FROM THE FBI
ACADEMY IN DECEMBER OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. HE WAS FORCED
INTO RETIREMENT AFTER BEING
INVOLVED IN AN ON DUTY HEAD ON
COLLISION. SERVING A TOTAL OF
TWENTY NINE YEARS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. HE
CONTINUED HIS PUBLIC SERVICE BY
BEING ELECTED TO THE LANCASTER
CITY COUNCIL. WHICH ALSO
INCLUDED HIM SERVING AS MAYOR
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE LEANED.
HIS DAUGHTERS BARBARA AND
SANDY. THE SUN DOWN AS WELL AS
TWELVE GRANDCHILDREN. AND EVEN
MORE GREAT GRAND CHILDREN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
ELLSWORTH EVERITT GROVES. HANK
YOU MITCHELL ACTING. MS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IT'S
WITH A AN EXTREMELY HEAVY HEART
THAT I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
HANNAH A LIVIA FRIDAY. RESIDENT
OF SAN DIEGO. HOW TO PRY PASSED
AWAY SUDDENLY AND UNEXPECTEDLY
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. ON MAY
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
SHE WAS BORN IN SAN DIEGO ON
DECEMBER SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
TO. HANNAH WAS A SENIOR IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND WORKED AS A HOSTESS
AT A LOCAL RESTAURANT. HANNAH
BEGAN SWIMMING WITHIN HER FIRST
WEEK FEW WEEKS OF LIFE AND LOVE
BEING NEAR THE WATER WEATHER
WAS GOING TO THE BEACH. OR
SWIMMING IN THE POOLS. I'M SUCH
A YOUNG AGE SHE WAS A SOCIAL
BUTTERFLY SHE SURROUNDED
HERSELF WITH COUNTLESS FRIENDS.
AND SHE WAS ALSO BIG SISTER
SOMETHING SHE TOOK SERIOUSLY.
AT A YOUNG AGE- HANNAH WOULD
JOIN HER MOTHER AT WORK WHO IS
A JOURNALIST AND AT THE AGE OF
TEN SHE BECAME A NEWSROOM STAR
HELPING CALL WATER DISTRICTS
GET INFORMATION OUT- TO THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE GREAT BLACK
OUT OF TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN SAN
DIEGO LOST ALL ITS POWER. CAN I
WAS ARTISTIC AND LOVED THE
OUTDOORS CHOPPED IN HIGH TO
TOOK PHOTOS OF NATURE. SHE
PLAYED SOCCER AND VOLLEYBALL
WAS FUNNY OUTGOING SMART. AND
KIND. I ALWAYS THINK OF HANNAH
IN THE NUMEROUS PICTURES HER
MOM HOST ALMOST DAILY AND
CONTINUES TO POST WITH A BRIGHT
INFECTIOUS SMILE AND A TWINKLE
IN HER EYE. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER PARENTS RICHARD FRY AND
WENDY FRY HER SISTER HAYLEY
ELIZABETH FRY OF SAN DIEGO HER
GRANDPARENTS JANET PRIVATE
STATEN LAURIE MAYER OF SAN
DIEGO. IN EARNEST AND CHERYL
MEYER OF GEORGETOWN TEXAS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU JOIN
ME INTERNING IN THE MEMORY OF
HANNAH FRY. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ. MISTER FLORIDA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN THE GERMAN OF JESSE
JESSE WAS BORN TO NELLY SKYLINE
COSTA RICA IN TWO THOUSAND ONE.
WHERE HE WAS LATER INTRODUCED
WAS FUTURE PARENTS WELL AS DAD
WAS VACATION IN SAN DIEGO.
NELLY ERNIE IN JESSE ALL CAME
BACK TO CALIFORNIA IS A FAMILY
OF THREE. WHICH WOULD
EVENTUALLY GROW INTO A FAMILY
OF SIX. JESSE PASSED AWAY IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
WHEN HE WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
BUT OVER A YEAR LATER MEMORIAL
STILL SITS STILL PRIZE. BUT TO
COUNTER PARKED DOWN THE STREET
FROM THEIR FAMILY HOME IS KEPT
ALIVE. BY HIS FRIENDS AND HIS
FAMILY. THIS ADJOURNMENT MEMORY
COMES NEARLY A YEAR AFTER HIS
PASSING AS A TESTAMENT TO THE
FACT THAT WHEN YOU LOSE A CHILD
STANTON TIME STANDS STILL. FOR
THIS I GOT IS JESSE'S MEMORY
STILL IS AS STRONG TODAY AS IT
WAS A YEAR AGO. AND CONTINUED
LOOPS THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES AS
WELL AS THE ON A PERSONAL NOTE
TO. EARNING AND- HIS MOTHER
NELLIE. HAVING GONE TO THE
SERVICE. YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
STRENGTH. THAT THESE TWO
INDIVIDUALS SHOWN. WHEN IT CAME
TO LAY IN THE REST OF THEIR SON
SO TURNING TO NELLY THANK YOU
FOR SHOWING WHAT IT MEANS TO
HAVE STRENGTH AND DIGNITY AT
THE TIME OF COMPLETE SADNESS
AND TRAGEDY WE LOVE YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOU AND THINKING
ABOUT YOU ALWAYS. MAY WE
ADJOURN AND JESSE'S NAME. THANK
YOU MISTER FLORA. MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESTINY PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MEMBERS
WE HAVE. ADDITIONAL BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY THE QUORUM
CALL REMAINS IN PLACE AT THIS
TIME.
MEMBERS WILL BE RESUMING
WITH SESSION WILL BE MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
NINE WILL READ. SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY NINE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC RELIEF IN THE MAKING A
PROVISION OF COURSE TAKE A
COMMUNITY RELATED BUDGET.
SOMEONE WORKING YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A B.
R. S. B. ONE THIRTY NINE IS THE
SECOND INSTALLMENT OF OUR
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS. THIS
PROVIDES FINANCIAL RELIEF FROM
LOWER MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
BY COVERT. THE PAYMENTS RANGE
FROM FIVE HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS. ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
OR INDIVIDUALS WHO FILED THE
CALIFORNIA INDIVIDUAL INCOME
TAX RETURN ON OR BEFORE.
OCTOBER FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IF SOMEONE WHO IS A
CALIFORNIA. RESIDENT FOR MORE
THAN ONE HALF THE TAX PER YEAR
BEGINNING ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. A SOMEONE
WHO CANNOT BE CLAIMED AS A
DEPENDENT. SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD
A CALIFORNIA JUST TO GROSS
INCOME. BETWEEN ONE DOLLAR BUT
NOT MORE THAN. SEVENTY FIVE.
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR NOT MORE
THAN THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
FIVE HUNDRED IN THE CASE OF A
MARRIED. INDIVIDUAL FILING
SEPARATELY. IF SOMEONE WHO HAD
WAGES SUBJECT TO WITHHOLDING.
UNDER DIVISION SIX OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR LESS. FOR THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FIVE HUNDRED
OR LESS. THE HUMANS WILL BE
DONE AT. WRITTEN FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR QUALIFIED RECIPIENT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
IN THE CASE OF A MARRIED
INDIVIDUAL FILING SEPARATELY
FOR SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN THE
CASE OF MERRY INDIVIDUAL FILING
SEPARATELY TO QUALIFIED
RECIPIENTS DID NOT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS NUMBER ONE.
SIMILAR TO THE GOAL OF THE
SYSTEM THIS ONE THIS BILL BE
ADOPTED IN FEBRUARY. PROVIDES A
PROVISIONS TO ACCEPT PAYMENTS
FROM OFFSETS IN GARNISHMENT
ORDERS IT ALSO PROVIDES A
FILING EXTENSION FOR ITIN
FILERS WHO APPLIED FOR THE I.
TEN. BUT HAVE NOT RECEIVED
THERE ARE TEN THESE QUALIFY
TAXPAYERS HAVE UNTIL FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO FILE TO COLLECT BOTH GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS ONE. AND TWO
MEMBERS THIS PROVIDES EIGHT
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
RELIEF TO LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
INDIVIDUALS REALLY PROVIDES
UPON THE BELIEF THAT THEY
SORELY NEED FOR THOSE PEOPLE
FROM THE VERY VERY CHALLENGING
YEAR WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I VOTE FOR. SB ONE THIRTY
NINE. THEY CAN DETAIN AS A
MEMBER FONG RECOGNIZE YOUR DESK.
I THINK THIS IS BIGGER. THE
GOLDEN STATE SIMILIS HAS PUT
MONEY IN THE POCKETS OF
HARDWORKING CALIFORNIANS HAVE
STRUGGLE TO PAY RENT UTILITY
BILLS AND PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLE THE STATE SURPLUS IS
CLEARLY AN INDICATION THAT MORE
TAX DOLLARS SHOULD BE RETURNED.
BACK TO HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AVERAGING ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS FONG. I SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CARCLUB RURAL
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THAT A VOTE. THIS IS A FIFTY
FOUR VOTE BILL.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A AS FIFTY
NINE KNOWS. SIX THAT MEASURE
PASSES WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS IS SB
ONE FORTY TWO. SB ONE FORTY TWO.
CARBERY SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
TWO BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE EMPLOYMENT
MAKING APPROPRIATION ARE FORCED
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MR CAME
MAKE IT OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB ONE FORTY TWO
PROVIDES. LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION OF THE MO USE
BETWEEN THE STATE AND THE
FOLLOWING NINETEEN STATE
EMPLOYEE. BARGAINING UNITS IT'S
S. C. ARE YOU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND BARGAINING UNIT ONE.
ADMINISTRATIVE FINANCIAL STUFF
SERVICES BARGAINING UNIT THREE.
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATORS
LIBRARIANS BARGAINING UNIFORM
OFFICE IN ALLIED. BARGAINING
UNIT ELEVEN ENGINEERING AND
SCIENTIFIC TECHNICIANS. WORKING
YOU KNOW FOURTEEN PRINTING
TRADES PARTY UNIT FIFTEEN
ALLIED SERVICES. BARGAIN YOU
KNOW SEVENTEEN REGISTERED
NURSES BARGAINING UNIT TWENTY
MEDICAL AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
BARGAINING UNIT TWENTY ONE
EDUCATION CONSULTANT FOR
LIBRARY EMPLOYEES. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
HEARING OFFICERS AND STATE
EMPLOYMENTS CASE. BARGAINING
UNIT TO ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
HEARING OFFICERS. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN BARGAIN UNIV
FIVE. CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY BARGAINING
UNIT SEVEN PROTECTIVE SERVICES
THE PUBLIC SAFETY. PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT BARGAINING UNIT NINE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS.
BARGAINING UNIT TEN
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS BARGAINING
UNIT TWELVE CRAFT IN
MAINTENANCE. INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF OPERATING ENGINEERS
BARGAINING IN THE THIRTEEN
STATIONARY ENGINEERS. UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS PARKING IN A SIXTEEN
POSITIONS DENTISTS AND
PODIATRISTS. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS BARGAIN EIGHTEEN
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. OFFICE
ME BURDEN YOU. TO NINETEEN
PROFESSIONAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. MOST NOTABLY THE AMMO
YOU AGREEMENT THE PER LEAVE
PROGRAM FROM LAST YEAR WHICH IS
ADOPTED TO ADDRESS OUR BUDGET
SHORTFALL OF TWENTY TWENTY.
DEPENDING ON THE BARGAINING
UNIT STATE EMPLOYEE WAS STATE
EMPLOYEE PAY WAS REDUCED
BETWEEN FOUR POINT 6% TO NINE
POINT THREE OR OR NINE POINT
23% THESE AGREEMENTS MEANS THE
EMPLOYEES WILL NO LONGER HAVE
THEIR PAY REDUCED. IT HELPS
MAKE THEM WHOLE MOVING FORWARD
FROM THE PICKUPS FROM LAST
YEAR. THE NEW CONTRACT ALSO
RESTORE EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR PREPAID RETIREE HEALTH
BENEFITS. STATE EMPLOYEES WILL
RESUME CONTRIBUTING A
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR PAY TO PRE
FUND THE RETIREE HEALTH
BENEFITS. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES ONE POINT THREE
BILLION TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THESE AND MORE
YEARS I WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE FOR SB. ONE
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU MICHELLE.
MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE MADE THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO SUSPEND A
NUMBER OF BENEFITS AND REDUCE
THE PAY TO MANY INCLUDING OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS WHO ARE
FACING WHAT WE THOUGHT WERE
DARK FINANCIAL TIMES THIS
RESTORES OUR PAY THIS YEAR WAS
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING YEAR FOR
SO MANY IN OUR STATE ESPECIALLY
IN OUR PUBLIC SAFETY. OF GROUPS
I URGE I ABOUT. THANK YOU MR
FONG SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESERVE A.
CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE. AND TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS SIXTY NO. ZERO AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION AND MEDIA
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE
FORTY SIX SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
SIX. AND THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY SIX BY
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY PYRALIDAE TO THE
BUDGET. THIS RETAIN YOU MAY
AGAIN OPEN THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKER SB ONE FORTY SIX
IMPLEMENTS TO CHANGES REGARDING
PUBLIC SAFETY FACILITIES. FIRST
THE DECREASES THE REVENUE BONDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF LOCAL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FACILITIES. THE BUDGET
PACKAGE WE PURPOSES THIS
FUNDING TO COUNTIES FOR LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH BED CAPACITY
GRANTS. IT ALSO REDUCES THE
AMOUNT AVAILABLE FOR THE HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS IN STATE PRISONS OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT
WILL BE SHIFTED. FROM LEASE
REVENUE BOND TO GENERAL FUND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE ON SB ONE FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU MR CHANG MR FONGYOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ONE FORTY SIX
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE TAKEN ON
THE BURDENS OF STATE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING REALIGNMENT. TO HELP
THE STATE MANAGED PRISON
POPULATIONS IN RETURN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EXPECTS THE STATE TO
HONOR ITS COMMITMENT AND HELP
FUND LOCAL JAIL CONSTRUCTION.
IT IS INCREDIBLY IRRESPONSIBLE
AND DISINGENUOUS FOR THE STATE
TO GO BACK ON ITS PROMISE AND
LEAVE COUNTIES HIGH AND DRY.
WELL GOVERNMENT HAS STEPPED UP
THE STATE MUST LIVE UP TO ITS
OBLIGATIONS I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MR FONG SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
BUDGET ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL.
TELLURIDE'S FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
SIXTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION A
MEDIA TRANSMETAL. TO THE SENATE.
THERE IS WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE. SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
SEVEN SB ONE FOUR SEVEN.
CORKERY SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
SEVEN BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
ENACT A LIVING TO THE STATE
BUDGET MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BROKE BUDGET BILL.
MISTER CHANG AND MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU MR SB ONE FORTY SEVEN
IS AN ANNUAL BILL THAT WE DO
EVERY YEAR TO SETTLE UP. PHILIP
COSTS WHICH WERE UNANTICIPATED
THEY NEEDED TO BE APPROPRIATED
THIS YEAR'S BILL IS ACTUALLY
RATHER SMALL BECAUSE WE'VE
ALREADY DONE SO MANY.
ADDITIONAL APPROPRIATIONS BILL
EARLIER THIS YEAR. APPROPRIATE
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL COSTS
PRIMARILY AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. THESE COSTS
WERE READY ASSUME TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PACKAGE AND
WITHOUT RESPECT FOR US FOR AYE
VOTE ON SB ONE FORTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER TANK THERE MR
FONG YOUR RECORD. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FORTY SEVEN
THE COST OF NECESSARY
IMPROVEMENTS TO CDC ARE
FOLLOWING THE ARMSTRONG CASE
NEEDS TO BE MADE QUICKLY AND IT
IS PRUDENT FOR THE STATE TO
SUPPORT THESE COSTS. THE
OUTCOME OF THE CASE WILL
IMPROVE SAFETY OUR PRISONS
KEEPING CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
AND INMATES SAFE HIRES I'VE OF.
THANK YOU MR FONG. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. A COUPLE OF OTHER
ALL MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADEBAYO. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL. INTELLI
THE VOTE HIGHS SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATELY
TRANSMETAL TO THE SENATE. K.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS SENATE BILL. ONE
FIVE EIGHT. SB ONE FIVE EIGHT
CORKERY SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY
EIGHT BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACCOLADE A HAZARDOUS WASTE
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE A COMMUNITY ABILITY TO
THE BUDGET. MISTER K. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
BILL REPRESENTS YEARS AND YEARS
OF WORK TO REFORM THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL IN THE FIRST RECOGNIZED
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM BELL
GARDENS FOR HER DEDICATION AND
PERSEVERANCE OF THIS ISSUE
AFTER YEARS OF LEGISLATIVE
ATTEMPTS HOURS OF NEGOTIATION
COUNTLESS STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT TO REFORM
D. TSC. PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
OVERSIGHT AND GOVERNANCE SIX OF
THE DEPARTMENT STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT WHILE REDUCING FEES FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES APPROPRIATE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO CLEAN UP
HAZARDOUS SITES INCLUDING THE
INFAMOUS EXIDE BATTERY FACILITY.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL CREATES
A FIVE MEMBER BOARD WITHIN THE
CAL THE PA TO OVERSEE AND
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY TO D. SEE
ALL OFFICIAL REPRESENT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC INTEREST IN ME
SPECIFIC SPECIFIED
QUALIFICATIONS. UPDATE THE
REQUIREMENT D. TNCS TO DEVELOP.
THE STATE WHITE HOUSE WITH
MITCHELL PLAN IN THE PART THE
PLAN BE APPROVED BY THE BOARD.
THE PLAN WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
INCLUDE AN IDENTIFICATION OF
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT BY A
HAZARDOUS WASTE TREATMENT AND
DISPOSAL ACTIVITIES. CONTAINS A
DESCRIPTION OF STEPS TO REDUCE
THE GENERATION OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE. INVOLVED A PUBLIC
PROCESS WITH MEETINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
COMPLETED BY MARCH FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AN UPDATED EVERY
THREE YEARS THEREAFTER AND
PROVIDE ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE FIRST
PLAN. IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
OWNER OPERATOR FOR HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITIES SUBMIT TO D.
T. S. C. A. WRITTEN COST
ESTIMATE. A SOCIALLY WITH
NECESSARY CORRECTIVE ACTION
AFTER DTS IS IDENTIFIED A
RELEASE OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
APPLYING. THIS SAME PROCESS
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES FOR CLEAN
UP SITES. ELIMINATES THE
MANDAMUS THE MANIFEST FEED
DISPOSAL FEE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY
IDENTIFICATION VIA REVISES AND
RE CAST A RAISES. THE FACILITY
FEE AND GENERATION HAMLEY FEE
TO BASE RATES THAT REFLECT THE
DTS IS ANTICIPATED REGULATORY
COSTS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
IT ALSO ELIMINATES THE
GENERATION HAMLEY FEE FOR USED
OIL AND ALLOW THE BOARD TO
RAISE THE FACILITY FEE AND THE
GENEROUS HELATHY ABOVE THE BASE
RATE. SUBJECT TO A CAP TO FUND
APPROPRIATIONS APPROVED BY. THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE BUDGET.
THE BILL ROWELL REVISES THE-
FEE THERE'S A- TO THE TALKS
SUBSTANCES. ELIMINATE THE FEE
BUSINESSES WITH LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. IT MAINTAINS
THE FAVORITE ON BUSINESSES
WITH. ONE HUNDRED TO FIVE
DEPLOYS AND RAISES THE RATE ON
BUSINESSES WITH MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED PLEASE. IT ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD TO REVISE
THE FEE RATES ANNUALLY TO FIND
ANNUAL APPROPRIATIONS APPROVED.
BY THE LEGISLATURE FROM T. S.
C. A. PHASES IT AT THE BILL
OFFERS IN A REQUIREMENT THAT
ALL PERMIT RENEWAL APPLICATIONS
MUST BE SUBMITTED AT LEAST TWO
YEARS BEFORE EXPIRATION. DEEMS
A PERMIT EXTENDED UNTIL THE TNC
TAKES FINAL ACTION ON THE
APPLICATION. OF THE RULE
APPLICATION SUBMITTED IN TIME.
THE STOCK WAS THE PROCESS BY
WHICH THE BOARD MAY REVIEW ANY
FINAL PERMIT DECISION THE DTS
IS NOT MADE BY THESE DEADLINES
AND- FINALLY REQUIRES THE TNC
TO POST. ON ITS WEBSITE A
TIMELINE OF THE ESTIMATED DATES
OF MILESTONES IN THE
APPLICATION REVIEW PROCESS
WITHIN NINETY DAYS OF
RECEIVING. THE COMPLETED
APPLICATION FOR A RENEWAL OF A
HAZARDOUS WASTE PERMIT. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE ON. SB ONE FIVE EIGHT.
THANK TO ENGLISH. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE STATE
HAS TAKEN AND THIRTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS MORE IN TAXES
THAN WE ANTICIPATED CLEARLY
CALIFORNIANS AND BIT AND
BUSINESSES IN OUR STATE ARE
OVERTAXED WHICH BEGS THE
QUESTION WHY ARE WE STILL
CONSIDERING RAISING TAXES. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FEE TAX WOULD
INCREASE BY OVER 3% FOR MANY OF
THE BUSINESSES TO BE REGULATED
BY THE CREATION OF THIS NEW
BOARD. EMPLOYERS COULD END UP
PAYING BETWEEN 1-000-024-0000
DOLLARS MORE PER YEAR UNDER
THIS NEW PROPOSAL TROUBLING
TAXES ON BUSINESSES IS WHAT
DRIVES INDUSTRIES OUT OF OUR
STATE WE SHARE A COMMITMENT FOR
A SAFE AND HEALTHY STATE AS YOU
WORK TO REOPEN THE STATE AND
LEAVE THE PANDEMIC BEHIND US.
BUT THIS PROPOSAL GROWS A
FEELING PROPHECY AND THREATENS
TO PUT NEEDED BUSINESSES OUT OF
BUSINESS HI ARJUN ABOUT. THANK
YOU MR FONG MISS GARCIA. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU IRIS
IS A PART OF THIS BILL AND I. I
WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
LETTER TO CERTAIN OPPOSITION WE
START OFF BY SAYING THAT. THIS
BILL PROVIDES RELIEF FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BUSINESSES THAT WERE
CURRENTLY ARE CURRENTLY PAYING
A FEE OR NO LONGER GONNA HAVE
TO PAY THAT FEE. IN ADDITION
INDUSTRY WITH MORE THAN FIVE
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN ENGAGED AT
THE TABLE WITH US AND THEY ARE
PREPARED TO PLAY THIS EXTRA
FEES BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT FOR A LONG TIME THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE. AND NOT PAYING THEIR
FAIR SHARE MEANS THAT
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE GET
TREATED LIKE WE'RE A WASTELAND
LIKE WHERE THE FULL CIVIL AND
IT'S OKAY LET S. B. STICKER ON
A REGULAR BASIS GENERATION
AFTER GENERATION. AND SO ALL WE
ARE DOING HERE IS DOING WHAT WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME
AGO AND ACTING ESPONSIBLY OUT
THERE WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION ON
FILE FOR MANY OF THESE
INDUSTRIES BECAUSE THEY
REALIZE. THAT THEY WANT TO BE
OUR PARTNERS AND THEY WANT TO
CHANGE CENTER ABOUT THEIR
ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE ARE HEALTHY WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT EXCITED MY BACKYARD
BUT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE WHOLE
STATE. THAT ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT BOTH FROM TE TOXIC
CLEANUP BUT ALSO FROM ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE BETTER FINANCIAL
ASSURANCES ALONG THE WAY THAT
WE HAVE HEALTHCARE COMMUNITIES
ALONG THE WAY. AND THAT WE HAVE
A DEPARTMENT THAT ACTUALLYIS
DOING HIS JOB PROPERLY BOTH ON
PERMITTING BUT ALSO ON
ENFORCEMENT ALONG THE WAY
INSIDE THE END OF THE DAY THE
FAILURE THAT WE SEE WITH
EXCITED ARE NOT YOU NEED TO
JUST ACCEPT YOU SEEN THEM
ACROSS THE STATE. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ONE
CALIFORNIA THAT WE MADE THAT
PROMISE AND IS NOT TO
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT YOUR ZIP
CODE OR YOUR ETHNICITY OR YOUR
INCOME SHOULD NOT DICTATE THE
LEVEL OF HELL TO GET TO HAVE ON
A REGULAR BASIS AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I WANT TO THINK THAT-
COUNTLESS PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR YEARS IT'S
BEEN. MANY YEARS THAT THIS HAS
BEEN IN IN OREGON SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF ALL THE
MEMBERS IN THE LEADERSHIP THAT
HAS BEEN STEADFAST INCLUDING
THE SPEAKER ON ENSURING THAT WE
FINALLY GET TO THIS HISTORIC
MOMENT THAT WE HAVE TODAY.
SUMMER YOU GONNA ASK ME NEXT
YEAR WHERE WE DOING SOME MORE
BILLS IN THIS SPACE THIS IS A
BIG STEP FORWARD WITH THE
REALITIES THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO DO MORE AS WE
LEARN MORE. ALONG THE WAY AND
SO PROUD OF TO THIS WORK WANT
TO BE CLEAR. THAT THERE'S LOTS
TO BE DONE ALONG THE WAY
THROUGH- RIVERS. GENERAL OF
HISTORIC. RUN DO. THESE CAN.
THANK YOU. THANK HEROES GARCIA
AND AS PARA QUE HAVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBER FROM EL GARDENS FOR
HER EFFORT OVER MANY MANY YEARS
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR FROM
MATERIALS THE MEMBER FROM
HAYWARD. WHO INSURE THAT NOT
ONLY DOES THIS BILL DO
EVERYTHING THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST MENTIONED TO ENSURE THEY
WERE CLEANING UP CALIFORNIA BUT
WE'VE ALSO PUSHED THE AGENCY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS MONEY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS THE DGSE HAS NOT
BEEN SPENDING THEIR MONEY
RESPONSIBLY WE HAVE NOT SEEN
PERMITS GOING OUT IN TIME WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THESE CLEANUPS
HAPPENING. AND UNDER NEW
LEADERSHIP THE AGENCY HAS PUT
OUT PUBLIC METRICS ON THEIR
WEBSITE INVITE INVITE YOU ALL
TO LOOK AT IT IT'S ACTUALLY
VERY IMPRESSIVE WHERE WE CAN
SEE THE WORK THEY'RE DOING
WHETHER THEY'RE HITTING THOSE
METRICS AND ENSURE THAT THE
MONEY THAT IS GOING TO THIS
AGENCY IS WELL SPENT WHICH I
THINK IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF
EVERYTHING WE DO. IT WAS UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE CHAIR
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THOSE METRICS ARE LIVE BEFORE
TAKING THAT VOTE TODAY SO I
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON. SB. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
QUE HAN. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
MISTER CHENEY MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER-
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BELL GARDENS
AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUE MARIN
DIVING CENTER VERY VERY WELL
THIS IS A VERY CHALLENGING
DEPARTMENT THIS HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN VEXING
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE WE'VE HAD- MANUFACTURERS.
CONSISTENTLY POLLUTE ESPECIALLY
IN INCOME AND IN SORRY THE
COMMUNITIES SPECIALLY WITH
LOWER INCOMES OF WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES AND THEY REALLY
HAVEN'T HAD TO PAY ANYTHING TO
REMEDIATE IT MUCH OF THE TOXIC
POLLUTION THAT HAS OCCURRED IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THIS IS A
HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO REALLY RAIN IN ONE
OF OUR CHAT MOST CHALLENGING
DEPARTMENTS IT'S A MAJOR MAJOR
FIRST STEP THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
SO MUCH SUPPORT FROM SO MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. BUT WE KNOW
THAT THE JOB IS NOT DONE
THEY'RE THEY'RE STILL GOING TO
BE A SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT AND
HAS BEEN DONE BY THIS BODY WE
ALSO ACTUALLY NEED TO CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THIS NEW BOARD SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AFTER I BOWED ON S. B. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
TANK WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROL. ALL MEMBERS FOR
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. MEMBERS
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
WE'RE
STILL SHORT MEMBERS ALL THEIR
RESOURCES OUT OF IT. THIS IS A
FIFTY FOUR VOTE BILL MEMBERS.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. TO THE SENATE.
WHATEVER WITH THE NUMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING UP.
CERVANTES CONCURRENCE ITEMS.
BEFORE WE TAKE UP THOSE
CONCURRENCE ITEMS WE ARE GOING
TO GO TO THE THIRD READING FILE
THIS IS THE THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN H. A R.
SIXTEEN BY MS RAMOS CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES RELATIVES IMMIGRATION.
MISS REYES ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU
AJ ARE SIXTEEN WHICH CALLS ON
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND
TO PASS SENSIBLE IMMIGRATION
REFORM FOR THE ELEVEN MILLION
IMMIGRANTS PRESENT IN THE
UNITED STATES. IT HAS BEEN OVER
THIRTY YEARS SINCE THE LAST
IMMIGRATION REFORM. THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS OUTDATED AND DOESN'T
MEET THE CHALLENGES OF TODAY OR
BEYOND. ALTHOUGH THIS IS A
FEDERAL ISSUE THIS IS AN ISSUE
IN WHICH CALIFORNIA HAS A LARGE
STAKE HIM. CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO THE LARGEST IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY AND RECENT DATA.
FINDS THAT APPROXIMATELY 27% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION IS
FOREIGN BORN. HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN HAVE AT
LEAST ONE IMMIGRANT PARENTS AND
ONE IN EVERY TEN WORKERS IS
UNDOCUMENTED. WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT IMMIGRATION REFORM FOR
OUR FRIENDS OUR NEIGHBORS OUR
FAMILIES. AND FOR OUR CENTRAL
WORKERS. IMMIGRANTS HAVE DEEP
TIES IN CALIFORNIA TO THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES AND TO
THE THAT THEY CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FABRIC OF OUR SOCIETY. THERE'S
NO BETTER TIME THAN NOW TO PASS
SENSIBLE IMMIGRATION REFORM FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE IN EVERY WAY PART
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE GREATER
UNITED STATES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS
REYES MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF A J. R. SIXTEEN. THIS
RESOLUTION WOULD URGE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO WORK
TOGETHER TO HUMANELY FIX OUR
BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM. THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT WE AS A BODY
OF TAKING UP TIME AND TIME
AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S WORTH
REPEATING. A BROKEN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM BENEFITS NO ONE AND ONLY
SEEKS TO HURT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. THIS IS A
DISTINCTLY CALIFORNIA ISSUE AS
ONE IN TEN WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA IS AN UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT. THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND HAVE TIME AND TIME
AGAIN SHOWN HOW CRITICAL THEY
ARE TO OUR SOCIETY. THEY
DESERVE A CHANCE TO BE PART OF
OUR COUNTRY A COUNTRY THAT THEY
HELPED BUILD I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS RACE
WHICH IS LIKE CO AUTHOR SOME
REST ON THE JOINT RESOLUTION
EVER SINCE FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE H. A R. COUPLE OF NARAL.
HOW AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
BEING ABLE. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ON A CHAIR. SIXTEEN
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE THERE
ARE FIFTY THREE CO AUTHORS
ADDED THIS IS A MAJOR A. R. WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS SAID
ABOUT. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF. HIGHS FIFTY TWO KNOWS
ONE THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
AND NOW MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE CONCURRENCE FILE TO
TAKE UP SOME ITEMS STARTING
WITH MR LEVINE'S FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB EIGHT NINETEEN.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY MR LEVINE EMAIL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB
EIGHT NINETEEN. FOR CONCURRENCE
VOTE FOR ONLINE SEEK WITH
VIOLENCE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MICHELLE
VAN. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE KIND OF A-
HIGHS SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS. MARKING
CURTAIN. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE. AND THE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
AN ACTIVITY TO JUVENILES.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU MAIL IT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB EIGHT FORTY ONES
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AFTER
TAKING MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE THIS
BILL WILL HELP FOSTER YOUTH
THAT WILL HELP KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER IT'S GONE THROUGH BOTH
HOUSES WITHOUT A NO VOTE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK REYES CUNNINGHAM. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. CARCLUB GIRLS ALL MY
RESEARCH. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE AND HOW
THE VOTE HIGHS SEVENTY FIVE. NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WHERE WE MOVED TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT BY MR
FONG IN THE CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES MISTER FARUQI
MAILBOX. I THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINE EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE
DMV FROM CHARGING CALIFORNIANS
MORE THAN THE COST OF THE
ACTUAL SERVICE MEMBERS WERE
TAKEN TO CLARIFY THAT THESE%
PROVISIONS WOULD ALSO EXTEND TO
PRE AUTHORIZED ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS COPING ABILITY JOINT
EFFORT WITH THE FORMER CHAIR OF
THE CONSUMER PRIVACY PROTECTION
COMMITTEE MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY AB THREE
NINE EIGHT PASSED IN BOTH
HOUSES ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU MR FONG.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLICK LIBERAL. IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
OF A DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI THE VOTE I
SEVENTY FOUR. NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN BY MISS RUBIO THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AN ACCOLADE
INTO CHILD ABUSE. THIS RUBIO
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
FROM THE SENATE THIS MEASURE IS
A FOLLOW UP TO OUR EFFORTS LAST
YEAR SURROUNDING CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY CENTERS WHICH PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN INSTANCES OF
CHILD ABUSE. THAT'S MEASURE
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MEASURE REAL. SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OF EIGHT ON THIS
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRED ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WHILE WE HAVE A LAW ON
THE ACTION. I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RICHARD BLUM HAD A BIRTHDAY
LAST TUESDAY. HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
AND MISTER GIBSON. HER BIRTHDAY
ON SATURDAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALEX LEE HAD A BIRTHDAY ON
SUNDAY. NOW. WE WISH YOU HAD A
BIRTHDAY. THAT'S ANNA ROONEY S.
ENTRY IN THE CALENDAR. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ANYWAY MISTER IRVING.
MEMBERS. I'M EXCITED TO SAY WE
HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. YEAH. DOES
ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
YEAH SENATE HEARING ON. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATE BILL
SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY SOONER- CHAU
BOW GRANDMOTHERS AND ACKERLEY
TO IMPLEMENT. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE- CALENDAR.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESERVE A THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTE AND A DESIRE TO VOTE THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENT A VOTE THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE IN TYLER
HIGHS SEVENTY FIVE. NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THERE ARE AMENDMENTS AT
THE DESK. MEMBERS THERE ARE
MOMENTS AT THE DESK AMENDMENTS
TO SP. ONE TWENTY NINE. I
BELIEVE MR FLOOR HAS AMENDMENTS.
TO SENATE BILL. ONE TWENTY
NINE. MEMBERS. MISTER FLORIDA
HAS AMENDMENTS CORKERY SENATE
BILL ONE TWENTY NINE WITH
LIMITS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLUORESCENT ONE. MR FLOOR ON
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. THIS BUDGET IS
TO BUILD A FISCAL RESILIENCY IT
MUST FIRST REPAY THE FUND
WITHDRAWAL FROM THE STATE'S
RAINY DAY FUND IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY MINUTES AT THE DESK
WOULD REPLACE THE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TAKE FROM THE STATE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
WHICH WAS USED TO ADDRESS THE
DEFICIT THAT NEVER MATERIALIZED
THE STATE IS IN BETTER SHAPE
NOW THAN WHEN THE GREAT
RECESSION STRUCK IN LATE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC IS PUSH FOR THE STATE TO
LEARN FROM THOSE YEARS AND
SUCCESS WE STRUCTURE THE FIRST
RAINY DAY FUND. PASSED AS
PROPOSITION TWO. OF TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. LAST YEAR
PROPOSITION TO GAVE STATE
LEADERS A SAVINGS ACCOUNT THAT
WAS NOT AVAILABLE WHEN
CALIFORNIA NEEDED TO BRIDGE A
ROUGHLY SIXTY. BILLION DOLLARS
IN BUDGET SHORTFALLS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE. BUT WHEN THE
FIFTY FOUR BILLION. DOLLAR
DEFICIT OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TURNED OUT TO BE WRONG IN
EFFECT THE BUDGET SURPLUS THE
FIRST ACTION AS THEY SHOULD
HAVE TAKEN WAS TO REPLACE THE
FUNDS SPENT FROM ITS SAVINGS
ACCOUNT. A TRUE RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET WOULD HAVE CONTINUED THE
DEFICIT I'M SORRY THE DECADES
EFFORT TO BUILD RESERVES TO
PROVIDE STABILITY IN TRUE
ECONOMIC TURN DOWNS. NOT SPEND
FROM THEM MEMBERS REVERSING THE
SEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR WITHDRAWAL WOULD MAKE
THE STATE MORE RESILIENT IN
FACE OF THE LIKELY. FUTURE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER FLOOR MISS
REYES HAD MOVED TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE. MS
RASMUSSEN LADY MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE SECOND BY MISTER CHOW.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE ONLINE THE MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
RAMOS IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN MISTER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
NO VOTE THIS IS PROCEDURAL MISS
RAMOS IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND MR FLORA AND NO. MAJORITY
PRESENT AND VOTING IS THE
THRESHOLD. WELL CLOSE ROLL EYES
FIFTY THREE KNOWS NINETEEN. HE
MEMBERS ARE LAID ON THE TABLE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS. THESE ARE MR SAY
OUR TOES AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY ARTURO SENT
TO MR SAY ARE TELL ON THE
MINUTES. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS FOR HEARING IS
AMENDMENTS. THAT'S FIFTEEN
YEARS OF FORCED CLOSURES AS
HAVE COMPLETELY DRAINED OUR
STATE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FUND. AS OF RIGHT NOW WE ARE
CLOSE TO TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OF DEBT OWED TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR LOANS TO
COVER THE DIFFERENCE OF OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT COST. AND THAT IS
EXPECTED TO GROW TO TWENTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS BY THE END OF
THE YEAR. CALIFORNIA'S
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS
EXCLUSIVELY PLATE PAID INTO BY
OUR EMPLOYERS IN THE COMMUNITY
YOUR STATE AND FEDERAL TAXES ON
WAGES. UNLESS THE STATE
INTERVENES ON THIS DEBT
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO BE
FORCED TO PAY. THIS THROUGH
ESCALATING TAXES EACH YEAR AND
THAT'S A LOT OF TAXES DID A
MAKE UP TWENTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS. YET NO WE'RE IN THE
BUDGET IS THERE ANY ALLOCATION
WHO ADDRESS THIS TREMENDOUS
DEBT. THIS FORECAST OF DEBT IS
ALMOST THREE TIMES THAT OF THE
WHAT IF IT'S CAUSED BY THE
RECESSION. AND AWAIT ON OUR
WORKERS AND BUSINESSES WILL BE
IN THE BILLIONS EACH YEAR AND
IT'S CLIMBING. THIS AMENDMENT I
HAVE INTRODUCED WILL
APPROPRIATE FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS TO PAY DOWN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE DEBT.
AND STILL LEAVE LOTS OF ROOM
FOR THE STATE TO FUND COUNTLESS
OTHER PROGRAMS IN NEEDS. I AM
PROPOSING FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE THE NET IMPACT
ON PAYING DOWN THIS MUCH OF OUR
PRINCIPAL DEBT WILL RESULT IN
LONG TERM REDUCTIONS IN OUR
STATE'S INTEREST PAYMENTS. AND
ADD TO FUTURE STABILITY.
MEMBERS WE HOLD ALMOST 40% OF
THIS YEAR FEDERAL LOANS. FOR
THE PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT. A
MAJORITY OF STATES HAVE ALREADY
PAID OFF THEIR DEBT AND IF WE
ARE TO BE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
WITH OUR TAXPAYERS MONEY WE
NEED TO DO THE SAME. IT IS FOR
THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
AMENDMENT THANK YOU. MS REYES I
MOVED TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE. THIS RACE MOVES AWAY
THE MEMBERS ON THE TABLE SECOND
BY MISTER CHOW. MEMBERS THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE. LOCAL OPEN
THE ROLE. ISRAEL IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE MR SAY OUR CHILDREN
KNOW MISS RACES ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MR SAY ARE TOàN NOW.
WELL CLOSE ROLE AS FIFTY FOUR.
NEWS EIGHTEEN MMS ARE LAID ON
THE TABLE. WE HAVE MORE
AMENDMENTS. THESE ARE MISTER
SMITH'S AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL ONE
TWENTY NINE WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIMILAR SET
THREE. MISTRESS MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I AM INTRODUCING AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD INVEST ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN WATER
STORAGE. WE ALL KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT WATER IS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN TO GET TO A
DROUGHT WE NEED TO STORE IT
WHEN WE HAVE A WET YEAR. AND
NOT LET IT GO OUT INTO THE
OCEAN. INSTEAD OF CREATING
REOCCURRING COST IN ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT COMMIT THE STATE
TO ONGOING SPENDING. WE SHOULD
INVEST IN WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. THAT WILL PROVIDE A
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
FAMILIES FARMERS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. THE OTHER DROUGHT
TOOLS SUCH AS WATER TRANSFERS.
CONSERVATION WATER REVIEWS
MAYBE HELPFUL. BUT STILL RELY
ON ACTUALLY HAVING WATER IN THE
SYSTEM. WE HAVE AN UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY WITH ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO INVEST IN THESE
PROJECTS. AS THE OLD ADAGE GOES
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T HAVE A WATER
PROBLEM. WE HAVE A WATER
STORAGE PROBLEM. ANOTHER OLD
ADAGE I THINK YOU'VE ALL HEARD.
WHISKEY'S FOR DRINKING AND
WATER FOR FIGHTING LET'S QUIT
FIGHTING OVER THE WATER. AND
LET'S WORK TOGETHER. THE STATE
HAS NOT SIGNIFICANTLY INVESTED
IN WATER STORAGE SINCE THE
VOTERS APPROVED PROP ONE AND
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. AND ALL
THOSE FUNDS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
AWARDED TO PROJECTS.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE ARE BEING TOLD TO
CONSERVE WATER. WE HAVE SMALL
FAMILY FARMS FOLLOWING THEIR
LAND WATER IS UNAVAILABLE AND
WE HAVE REAL COMMUNITIES AT
RISK OF THEIR DRINKING WELLS
GOING DRY. TODAY I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF INVESTING ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR WATER
SUPPLY PROJECTS THAT SO THAT WE
CAN BE PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
DROUGHT A QUICK COMPLAINING
EVERY FEW YEARS THAT WORK IN
ANOTHER DROUGHT BECAUSE WE DID
NOT STORE THE WATER WHEN WE HAD
TO WAIT YEAR. OR ON HIGH SNOW
PACK. PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
AMENDMENT. MS REYES I MOVED TO
LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
MISS RASMUSSEN LADY MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE SECOND BY MISTER CHOW
MEMBERS THIS IS ANOTHER
PROCEDURAL VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. IS RACES ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE ONLY THE MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE. THIS RACE IS ASKING
FOR AND I AM MISTER SMITH IS
ASKING FOR A NO. MS RACES
ASKING FOR AN AYE MR SMITH THE
NO. MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THE MEMBERS ARE LAID
ON THE TABLE. WE HAVE MISTER
GALLAGHER'S AMENDMENTS. AT THE
DESK THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY NINE
WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER SET FOR. MR
GALLAGHER ON THE MEMONS. THANK
YOU MEMBERS A- I BESEECH THIS
BODY. THIS AFTER I KNOW IT'S
GETTING LATE IN THE HOUR BUT
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND I THINK IT'S A GRIEVOUS
OVERSIGHT. IN THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET. THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
SEEING A CUT. IN A STATUS QUO
BUDGET WHEN IT COMES TO
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. NOW WE ARE
GOING INTO WHAT COULD BE THE
WORST WILDFIRE SEASON. DRIER
CONDITIONS. HEATWAVES WE'RE
GOING TO WHAT COULD BE THE ONE
OF THE WORST WILDFIRE SEASONS.
AND THAT'S A SCARY PROSPECT
CONSIDERING WHAT WE BEEN
THROUGH. WHAT MY COMMUNITIES
BEEN THROUGH WHAT YOUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN THROUGH.
TO THEN HAVE A STATUS QUO
BUDGET AND EVEN A CUT FROM THE
MAY REVISE. INNER WILDFIRE
PREVENTION FUNDS. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR WE MADE A DEAL. WITH SB
NINE A ONE THAT WE WOULD PUT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
CAP AND TRADE FUNDS INTO
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EVERY YEAR.
IN THIS GOVERNOR HAS SAID HE
WANTS TO DOUBLE DOWN ON. WE'RE
GOING BACKWARDS LAST YEAR WE
DID CAP AND TRADE DIDN'T EVEN
FUND WILDFIRE PREVENTION. WE
PAY THAT BACK IN THE EARLY
ACTION FUNDS AND IN THIS BUDGET.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
THE GOVERNOR SAID HE WAS GONNA
HAVE A BILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE.
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION. THEN
IN MAY WHEN HE RELEASED THE
MAYOR REVISED SO IT'S GOING TO
BE A TWO BILLION DOLLAR.
PACKAGE AND IN THE BUDGET
YOU'RE VOTING ON TODAY IT'S TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S THE FACT. NOT A
BILLION IT'S NOT TWO BILLION.
IT'S TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A STATUS
QUO WILDFIRE PREVENTION BUDGET
IS NOT DOUBLING DOWN. IT'S NOT
GETTING OUT THE PROBLEM. AND
NOW NPR HAS BROKE THE STORY
THIS REVEALED THAT EVEN THE
STUFF THAT WE'VE- SAID WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON. WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THE JOB DONE THE
GOVERNOR TOUTED NINETY THOUSAND
ACRES TREATED IT'S. ELEVEN
THOUSAND. WHEN WE NEED TO BE
DOING FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EVERY ALL THE EXPERTS ARE
SAYING FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES NEED TO BE TREATED EVERY
YEAR TO GET ON TOP OF THE
PROBLEM. THE PROBLEM IS FUEL.
WE HAVE AN OVERGROWTH OF FUELS
IN OUR WILD LANDS. YOU DON'T
GET OUT THAT WITHOUT GETTING
OUT THERE DOING THE WORK THE
THINNING. THE FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT THE PRESCRIBERS.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING LIKE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING REAL BIG. LIKE
WE'RE DOING ALL THESE THINGS IT
IS NOT HAPPENING. WE'RE NOT
REMOVING THE BARRIERS TOM
PORTER. CALIFORNIA FIRE CAPTAIN
IS SAID WE HAVE NOT REMOVED THE
BUREAUCRATIC. SEQUEL BARRIERS
AND OTHER BARRIERS THAT KEEP US
FROM DOING THIS WORK QUICKLY
AND TIMELY. THE TIME IS NOW. WE
HAVE ANOTHER WILDFIRE SEASON ON
THE ON THE VERGE OF WE'RE JUST
GOING TO PASS A STATUS QUO
BUDGET. IF THIS IS A PRIORITY
WE HAVE THE CHANCE TO CHANGE IT.
NOW THAT SAME ARTICLE I TALKED
ABOUT SAID CONTINUED. SUSTAIN
FUNDING IS WHAT IS NEEDED
THAT'S WHAT THIS AMENDMENT DOES.
IT SAYS FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WE ARE COMMITTED CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION. THE PUTTING THAT
MONEY IN THE BUDGET NOT SOME
PROMISE. THE MAYBE MAYBE WE'LL
GET AROUND TO IT IN THE NEXT
YEAR WE GOT A BAG AND FIGHT FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION FUNDS THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN HERE
AUTOMATICALLY EVERY YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT THIS AMENDMENT DOES.
I'M JUST ASKING YOU BECAUSE
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT AFFECTS ALL
OF OUR DISTRICTS WHETHER YOUR
FOR YOUR CITIES ARE. THREATENED
BY A CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE OR
THE SMOKE THAT'S IN THE AIR
AFTERWARDS. DON'T LET THIS JUST
GO BY MAN AND PASS ANOTHER
STATUS QUO BUDGET ON A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION DON'T ALLOW THIS
GOVERNOR TO GET AWAY WITH
SAYING HEY I'M DOING. MORE THAN
EVER ON WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
IT TURNS OUT NO IT'S NOT TRUE.
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND PUT
YOUR MONEY WHERE YOUR MOUTH IS.
AND I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
AMENDMENT CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATED FUNDING TO GET OUT
WHAT IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW. WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
STOPPING CARBON EMISSIONS.
THANK KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE AND KEEPING OUR AIRCRAFT
SAFE AND CLEAN. THIRTY SECONDS
YOU TO PASS THIS AMENDMENT.
DON'T LET THIS JUST BE A PARTY
LINE VOTE THANK YOU. THERE WAS
GALLAGHER MS REYES I MOVED TO
LAKE. THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE MS REYES MOVES AWAY THE
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE SECOND BY
MR CHILD MEMBERS AGAIN THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON NINETY
MINUTES ON THE TABLE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS RAMOS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MR
GALLAGHER IS ASKING FOR NO VOTE
MISS RACES ASKING FOR AN AYE MR
GALLAGHER NO. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FIFTY FOUR
DOLLARS TWENTY THE MEMBERS ARE
LAID ON THE TABLE. DR CHOI HAS
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL ONE
TWENTY NINE WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOICE AT FIVE
DR CHOI ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS I RISE TO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO SP ONE TWENTY
NINE THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED
TO THE ASSEMBLY DESK. ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO CHILDREN SO
SHE WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
STATE BUDGET. FOR EXPANDED
LEARNING TIME. THIS FUNDS ARE
PROVIDED A TO A SUPPORT.
CURRICULAR AND RICHEMONT THE
ACTIVITIES SO OUTSIDE THE
CLASSROOM INCLUDING EXPANDED
AFTER. SHOULD NOT BE EXCLUDED
BASED UPON THE OF GRAY WHAT
TYPE OF A PUBLIC SCHOOLS THEY
ATTEND. THE AMENDMENTS ARE I AM-
SAYING ACCOMPLISH TWO IMPORTANT
GOALS FIRST PROVIDE THIS FUNDS
SO TO SERVER ALL K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS NOT JUST THE
THROUGH SIX. SECOND PROVIDE THE
FUNDS TO ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHARTER SCHOOLS SO AND THE
STATE THE SPECIAL SCHOOL HOURS.
THIS AMENDMENT SO OR BENEFIT
DEAF AND BLIND OF CHILDREN'S AT
THE STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS AND
THE STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED. IN
NINE CLASSROOM BASED ON TOTAL
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU AND I
REQUEST OF YOU SO MEN MUST BE
ADOPTED IN S. B. ONE TWENTY
NINE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT ALL
OF OUR EDUCATION FOR ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR CHOI
BIZRATE'S I MOVED TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE MS
REYES MISCELLANY MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE SECONDED BY MR CHOW.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON LAYING
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
THIS IS PROCEDURAL MISS RACES
ASKING FOR AN EYE. DOCTOR CHOI
IS ASKING FOR A NO. A LADY
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. MAJORITY IN
PRESERVING CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLE HIGHS FIFTY THREE KNOWS
NINETEEN THE MEMBERS ARE LAID
ON THE TABLE. AND MISS DAVIS
HAS AMENDMENTS OF THE DESK AS
WELL MISTER MISTER- RE CLERK.
READ THE ADAM PLEASE. SENATE
BILL ONE TWENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES SET SIX THIS DAVIS ON
THE MENACE. MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AMENDMENT AB ONE TWENTY
NINE I'LL KEEP THIS SHORT AND
SWEET THIS IS A ONE YEAR GAS
TAX HOLIDAY. EVEN SHORTER
IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION IS
THE SECOND HIGHEST HOUSEHOLD
EXPENSE NEXT TO HOUSING. THE
NATION'S TEN MOST EXPENSIVE
CITIES FOR TRANSPORTATION COSTS
ARE ALL IN CALIFORNIA INFLATION
IS MAKING THE PROBLEM WORSE.
TRANSPORTATION COSTS HAVE
INCREASED 20% IN THE LAST YEAR
ALONE CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY
PAY THE HIGHEST GAS PRICES IN
THE COUNTRY AT FOUR DOLLARS AND
THIRTY CENTS A GALLON AND GOING
UP. THIS IS MORE THAN A WHOLE
DOLLAR MORE THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE AND THIRTY CENTS ABOVE
THE NEXT HIGHEST STATE WHICH IS
A WHITE. A MAJOR PART OF THIS
CRISIS TO THE GAS TAX
CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY PAY THE
HIGHEST GAS TAXES IN THE
COUNTRY. ADDING MORE THAN
EIGHTY CENTS TO THE COST OF A
GALLON OF GAS THIS IS MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE CENTS A GALLON
ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. THE
LEGISLATURE'S REYES FUEL AND
THE VEHICLE TAXES BY MORE THAN
FIVE BILLION A YEAR JUST FOUR
YEARS AGO. ONLY ON JULY FIRST
THOSE GAS TAXES ARE GOING UP
AGAIN. THROUGH HIS EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY GAVIN NEWSON COULD
KEVIN ANDERSON COULD PAUSE THIS
HIKE IF HE CHOOSES TO. WE HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY DO
THAT TODAY. WE SIT THERE WE
TALK ABOUT UNITY BUT THIS IS A
THIS IS A MOMENT THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIANS IN
THE STATE WINNERS WIN WIN ALL
THE WAY SO I ASK THAT YOU THINK
ABOUT IT LET'S DO SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY LIFT THE
BURDEN OF THOSE BETTER NEED
WHICH IS REALLY THE ENTIRE
STATE RIGHT NOW. I URGE THE
ADOPTION OF THIS AMENDMENT I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. IMAGE
RAISE YOUR DEMOCRATS. I MOVED
TO LADY AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE. MS REYES IS MOVING TO
LADY AMOUNTS ON THE TABLE
SECOND BY MISTER CHOW. MEMBERS
THIS IS PROCEDURAL CORPORAL.
WHEN I VOTE THIS DAVIES IS
ASKING FOR AND NOBLE MS RACES
ASKING FOR AN I. THIS DAVIES
YOU KNOW. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
NINETEEN THE MEMBERS ARE LAID
ON THE TABLE. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE BILL AND CHIEF WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS IS
SENATE BILL. ONE TWENTY NINE
CORRECT SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY
NINE BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
ACCORDING TO THE STATE BUDGET
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET
BILL MR TANG YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I AM
SO PROUD TO PRESENT SB ONE
TWENTY NINE THE AMENDMENT TO
OUR BUDGET BILL TO IT TWO WEEKS
AGO I STOOD HERE. AND WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW THIS TRULY IS. A
HISTORIC BUDGET. WHEN I STOOD
UP HERE A YEAR AGO. WE WERE
THREE MONTHS IN THE CLOVER WE
REALLY DIDN'T HAVEANY IDEA.
WHAT WE WERE GOING TO FACE FOR
THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS IT HAS
BEEN QUITE. A CRAZY RIDE. WE
PASS A PESSIMISTIC BUDGET WE
PASSED THE BUDGET THAT WE
THOUGHT. WAS GONNA BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE HUGE LOSS
OF REVENUE THAT WE ACTUALLY.
DIDN'T SEE. NOT ONLY DO WE NOT
SEE. REVENUE GO DOWN WE HAVE TO
SELL REVENUE GO UP. THERE ARE
KIND OF ME CONTINUING TO
GENERATE THE REVENUE THAT WE
SORELY NEED. TO HELP SO MANY
WORKING CALIFORNIA'S TO HELP
SOMEBODY STRUGGLING.
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE RELEASED
ARE BUDGET BLUEPRINT EARLIER
THIS YEAR WE TALKED ABOUT FOUR
MAJOR THEMES. ONE WAS TO
PRESERVE TO PRESERVE. THE
PROGRAM TO DOES REALLY BRING
BACK THE MONEY FROM THE CUTS
THAT WE HAD MADE. IN THIS YEAR
IN THIS CURRENT YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE WANTED TO RESPOND TO KOBE TO
MAKE SURE WE WERE DOING
EVERYTHING. TO RESPOND WHETHER
THAT WASON THE HEALTHCARE SIDE
WITH THE DEVIL IS LOOKING AT
WILD FIRES OR DROP REALLY
RESPONDING TO THE MOMENT FOR
THIS LAST TWELVE MONTHS. WE
ALSO WANTED TO PROTECT FAMILIES
WITHOUT SO MANY FAMILY SO MANY
SENIORS SO MANY KIDS. WHO
REALLY. ALREADY STRUGGLING
BEFORE. WE GOT TO THIS VERY
VERY POINT. AND THE LASTLY WE
KNOW WE IT WAS ENOUGH TO
PROTECT WE NEEDED TO RECOVER.
SO THIS BUDGET. DOES THAT AND
SO MUCH MORE. WE ARE ABLE TO
PRESERVE BY RESTORING ALL THE
CUTS THE LEAD IN BILLION
DOLLARS TO RESTORE THOSE CUTS
TO SENT TO SCHOOLS. ALL ACROSS
THE STATE I KNOW SO MANY FOLKS
WERE VERY FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE OUR SCHOOLS FOR ME HOLE AS
WELL AS UCCS YOU ARE COURTS. WE
RESPONDED. WE RESPONDED AND
THEN SOME THROUGHOUT THIS
ENTIRE YEAR WE JUST VOTED ON AN
EVICTION MORE TWENTY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DIDN'T SEE MASS
EVICTIONS WE HAD MORE TIME TO
GET MONEY OUT. TO STRUGGLING
TENANTS LANDLORDS WHO REALLY
REALLY NEED TO THOSE RESOURCES.
WE RESPONDED TO. EVERYTHING OF
NATIONAL THAT WE CAN SEE FROM
THIS PANDEMIC WHETHER IT WAS
MASS WHETHER IT WAS TESTING
WHETHER IT'S VACCINATION AND IT
FELT LIKE EVERY FEW MONTHS.
EVERYTHING WAS CONSTANTLY
CHANGING. THIS BUDGET IS ALSO
COMPLETELY ABOUT PROTECTION.
WHICH PROTECTION IT'S
PROTECTING THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WHO WORE ONE
PAYCHECK AWAY FROM HOMELESSNESS
FOUR ONE UNEMPLOYMENT CHECK
AWAY FROM HOMELESSNESS WHO WERE
ONE SERVICE AWAY FROM SOMETHING
ELSE HAPPENING TO THEM. WE SAW
YOU HEARD ME PRESENT ABOUT THE
GOLDEN STATE THE MOST EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS FOR FAMILIES
WHO DESPERATELY NEEDED MONEY
INTO GETTING MONEY BACK YOU SAW
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND GRANTS
THAT THEY NEEDED TO REALLY KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN. WE I
PROTECTING FAMILIES WHO REALLY
NEED HEALTH CARE WHAT WHAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT A PANDEMIC. THE
HEALTH CARE NOT ONLY ARE WE
TAKING WITH THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED FROM MEDIC MEDIC CAL
FOR SIXTY AND OLDER BUT NOW WE
ARE OFFERING MEDI CAL
REGARDLESS. OF HOW YOU ARE HERE
IN THIS STATE FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE FIFTY AND OVER. WE HAD A
RATE STUDY ON THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABLED COMMUNITY. WE SAW. I
THINK MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT IT
WAS ACADEMIC FOR ALL THOSE
FAMILIES WHO RELY ON THOSE
CENTERS EVERY SINGLE DAY IT WAS
ANYTHING BUT- WE ARE FINALLY.
MAKING THAT PROMISE THAT WE
HAVE PROMISED THEM. A REALITY.
SO OVER FIVE YEARS WE ARE WE
ARE DOING THAT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR. RATE INCREASE THAT WE
HAVE SO NEEDED TO DO FOR SO
MANY SO MANY YEARS.
HOMELESSNESS A YEAR AGO IT
SEEMS LIKE MORE THAN A YEAR AGO
BUT OVER A YEAR AGO THE
GOVERNOR WAS ON THIS FLOOR
TALKING ABOUT ONLY ONE ISSUE
AND ONE ISSUE ONLY WHICH IS
HOMELESSNESS. TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL MONEY TO
HOMELESSNESS ONE BILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR ONE BILLION
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS ISSUE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS NEXT YEAR.
THE CITIES COUNTIES CONTINUES
OF CURE TOTAL FLEXIBLE FUNDING
INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENT ON HOMELESSNESS BACK.
WE ALSO HEARD MONEY IS NOT
ENOUGH. WE HAVE TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIES
COUNTIES CAN TEAMS OF CARE
NONPROFIT EVERY DEVELOPER. WILL
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR EACH
AND EVERY SINGLE NICKEL WE'RE
INVESTING IN EVERY COMMUNITY.
EDUCATION FOR WHO THOUGHT RE
OPENING SCHOOLS WAS GOING TO BE
A CONTROVERSIAL TOPIC THIS YEAR
IF THE TALK WITHOUT GOING TO
SCHOOL IS A CONTROVERSIAL
TOPIC. YET WALLACE NOT ONLY ARE
WE GOING TO REOPEN SCHOOLS THE
SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO GET A
RECORD AMOUNT OF FUNDING OVER
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PER PUPIL SO NOT ONLY CAN THE
HELP WITH LEARNING RECOVERY BUT
THEY CAN ALSO GET THE CRITICAL
MONEY THEY NEED TO. LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR OUR CHILDREN
UNIVERSAL TICKET WE TALKED
ABOUT UNIVERSITY K. A YEAR AGO
IT'S BEEN YEARS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT UNIVERSAL T. K.
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS ONLY 25%
OF KIDS. GET TEEKAY NOW WE HAVE
A PROGRAM THAT EVERY SINGLE
FOUR YEAR OLD EVENTUALLY THE
STATE OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
WILL BE GETTING TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. EVERYWHERE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. SO MANY OF US I
ALWAYS JOKE WE END UP HIDING IN
MAY. IN APRIL BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN YOU SEE. LETTERS COME OUT.
THAT WE HAVE SO MANY FAMILIES
WHO. WORK HARD KIDS THAT WORK
HARD KICK IT INTO. THE UC OF
THEIR CHOICE. SO WE ARE BUYING.
UC SAN DIEGO UC BERKELEY UCLA
OUT. AND MAKING SURE. THAT WE
HAVE. MORE SLOTS OPEN THERE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. IT ON TOP OF THE
UC HAS ALWAYS. BEEN CRITICIZED
MITT MADE BY MANY OF US IN THIS
BODY FROM SPENDING TOO MUCH. ON
ADMINISTRATION. AND NOT ENOUGH
ON STUDENTS WE WILL CONTINUE.
THAT OVERSIGHT OVER THEIR
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT MONEY. DOESN'T GO TO
THE BUREAUCRATS IN OAKLAND BUT
MAKE SURE IT GETS IN THE
CLASSROOMS IN BERKELEY IN LOS
ANGELES. AND IN SAN DIEGO AND
ON TOP OF THAT WERE ALSO
INCLUDED. IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
MONEY FOR CSU SOPHOMORE.
CALIFORNIANS WHO COULDN'T GET
IN TO SEE ISSUE BECAUSE- MANY
BE IMPACTED. UNIVERSITIES
DIDN'T HAVE ROOM. ARE UNABLE TO
DO THAT. MEMBERS THIS REALLY IS
A BUDGET. OF A LIFETIME IT'S
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. A HUNDRED
NINETY SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
TERMS OF OUR GENERAL FUND. AND
FOR SO MANY OF US THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RESERVES THE
RECORD HIGH AMOUNT OF USERS.
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
RESERVES. THIS IS A BUDGET THAT
REALLY DEMONSTRATE THAT OUR
VALUES ARE PROTECTING. THE MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES THE
FAMILIES WHO NEED OUR HELP THE
MOST AT THE TIME OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT ALSO. WELL INTO
THE FUTURE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON SB ONE TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU MISTER TANK. MR FONG IF YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. A TWO WEEKS AGO
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A BUDGET
FRAMEWORK A FRAMEWORK THAT
RAISE CONCERNS OF ON
SUSTAINABILITY THAT LACK
IMPORTANT DETAILS AND DID NOT
PROVIDE ANY STRUCTURAL REFORMS
TO BROKEN AND MISMANAGED
PROGRAMS AND SYSTEMS TODAY.
WE'RE BEING ASKED TO PASS A
BUDGET YOU POINT NOW. THIS
SEQUEL IS JUST AS CONCERNING AS
THE ORIGINAL. THIS BILL
CONTAINS TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
AMENDMENTS AND HUNDREDS OF NEW
APPROPRIATIONS BUT STILL LACKS
IMPORTANT SPECIFICS AGAIN SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS WARRANT
MERIT. BUT THIS BILL LIKE THE
LAST FRANK FRAMEWORK FAILS TO
ADDRESS THE BASICS FOR
CALIFORNIANS IT DOES NOT BIG CD
AN ESSENTIAL SERVICE THAT MANY
UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS RELY ON
AS THEIR LIFELINE. A SYSTEM
THAT HAS A GROWING BACKLOG WITH
OVER ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
STILL TRAPPED IN ITS
BUREAUCRACY. IT DOES NOT PAY
DOWN THE MOUNTING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND DEBT NOT ONE
DOLLAR. AGAIN NOT ONE DOLLAR IS
IN THIS BUDGET FRAMEWORK THAT
DEALS WITH THIS THAT. THE
BIGGER THIS THAT GETS THE
HIGHER THE TAXES WILL GET FOR
BUSINESS IS STILL STRUGGLING ON
THE HILL THE ON THE HEELS OF
THIS PANDEMIC A DEBT THAT WAS
INCURRED BECAUSE OF STATE
MISMANAGEMENT. BY CONTINUING TO
DEPRIVE OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
SUBSTANTIAL SUBSTANTIAL RELIEF
THE STATE IS INCREASING AN
ALREADY HIGH TAX BURDEN IN
STIFLING THEIR ABILITY TO
RECOVER. ALREADY PERSEVERING
THROUGH UNCERTAINTY FAILING TO
ACT ON THIS CRITICAL PRIORITY
IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. THIS
BILL DOES NOT REPAY THE SEVEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS TAKEN AT THE RAINY DAY
FUND. WE ALL AGREE MORE SAVINGS
IS BETTER THAN SIMPLY MORE
SPENDING. EVEN MORE CONCERNING
IS THE INSUFFICIENT FUNDING TO
FIGHT WILDFIRES IN BRING RELIEF
TO THIS EXTREME DROUGHT.
WILDFIRE AND DROUGHT OR DUAL
THREATS THAT FACE CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW A WILDFIRE PREVENTION
THE RHETORIC ISN'T MATCHING THE
REALITY AS IT APPEARS THAT
THERE IS NOT A SIGNIFICANT
COMMITMENT TO WILDFIRE
PREVENTION FOR THIS UPCOMING
BUDGET YEAR. WE NOT ONLY NEED
CERTAINTY BUT SUSTAINED FUNDING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE MERE HOPE OF
MORE ACTION THE FUTURE IS
UNACCEPTABLE IN FACT THERE'S A
FIRE BURNING IN KERN COUNTY AT
THIS VERY MOMENT. WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WATER
STORAGE MUST BE PART OF ANY
LONG TERM JOB SOLUTION. AGAIN
THE DETAILS IN THIS AGREEMENT
STILL REMAIN LACKING. WE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ARE SEEING THE
HUMAN AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
OUR STATE'S FAILURE TO INVEST
IN WATER STORAGE YEARS AGO. WE
NEED STORAGE AND CONVEYANCE
IMPROVEMENTS TO ENSURE A
SUSTAINABLE AND RELIABLE WATER
SUPPLY FOR AND OUR ENTIRE STATE.
I'M AFRAID THAT THIS WILL BE
ANOTHER MISSED OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THESE GROWING AND
LOOMING THREATS. CALIFORNIANS
ARE FACING AN AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS IT'S UNDENIABLE IN
CALIFORNIANS AND BUSINESSES ARE
LEAVING OUR STATE. THAT'S
RESTORE PERMANENTLY THE TAX
RELIEF THAT IS NEEDED THAT WILL
HELP OUR ECONOMY AND MAKE OUR
STATE MORE COMPETITIVE TO OTHER
STATES. NOW IS THE TIME TO PLAN
RESPONSIBLY TO BUILD UP OUR
RESERVES ARE REDUCING THE
BURDENS ON SMALL BUSINESSES AND
FAMILIES. THE NEED FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION WATER STORAGE AND
PERMANENT TAX RELIEF OR JUST AS
URGENT NOW AS THEY WERE TWO
WEEKS AGO AND EVEN TWO YEARS
AGO AND CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL
SUFFERING UNDER MISMANAGEMENT
IN OUR STATE AGENCIES THAT
CONTINUE TO FAIL THEM. AS I
SAID TWO WEEKS AGO LOOKS CAN BE
DECEIVING. POURING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO BROKEN SYSTEMS
IT'S A RECIPE FOR DISASTER. OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE PLEADING
FOR RELIEF THAT THIS BUDGET
DOESN'T PROVIDE WE NEED TO
DEVELOP A SIGNIFICANT AND
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENTS AND
WHILE FOR PREVENTION AND WATER
STORAGE WHICH THE DETAILS STILL
ARE ARE NOT THERE. THIS BUDGET
ADMITTEDLY IS STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS BUT I'M AFRAID THAT
THIS BUDGET IS NOT ADEQUATE
TACKLING CRITICAL AND
FUNDAMENTAL NEEDS. EVERY
CALIFORNIAN EXPECTS US TO
TACKLE MEMBERS I URGE A NO VOTE
ON SB ONE TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU MR FONG MR KILEY. YOUR
RECORD LAST. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- WE CONSIDER THIS
BUDGET AT A MOMENT WHEN
CALIFORNIA LAGS BEHIND THE REST
OF THE NATION- IN ALMOST EVERY
WAY NOT BECAUSE OF A VIRUS
WHICH HIT EVERY STATE BUT
BECAUSE OF OUR GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSE. FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
NATIONAL OUT WIRE AND ALL THE
WORST WAYS. WE'VE GOT A LONGER
SCHOOL CLOSURES THE MOST
PUNISHING LOCKDOWNS AND THE
NATION'S WORST PERFORMING
BUREAUCRACY. AND THE RESULTS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN OUR SCHOOLS
HAVE EXPLODED. OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE HAS BEEN CLOSE TO THE
WORST IN THE COUNTRY. WHEN IT
COMES TO UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
BOTH THE BACKLOG OF UNRESOLVED
CLAIMS AND THE SCALE OF
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS IS
UNSURPASSED END. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTCOMES ARE AMONG THE
WORST IN THE COUNTRY WITH AN
EXCESS MORTALITY RATE HIGHER
THAN FORTY FOUR STATES. WITH
THIS UNDER PERFORMANCE ISN'T
JUST A RETROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS
IT CONTINUES INTO THE PRESENT
WITH AMONG THE NATION'S WEAKEST
ECONOMIC RECOVERIES. ABOUT HALF
OF THE JOBS THAT WERE LOST HAVE
BEEN RECOVERED AYE MERE HALF.
SMALL BUSINESS OPENINGS ARE
DOWN 40% OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT REMAIN OPEN 40%
ARE UNDERSTAFFED. THIS LAST
MONTH WE ADDED JUST TWELVE
THOUSAND WORKERS. NOW PART OF
THE PROBLEM IS THE STATE IS IT
RATIONALLY CLINGING TO A
PANDEMIC MENTALITY. WE REFUSED
AND OUR STATE OF EMERGENCY EVEN
THOUGH THE STATE OF NEW YORK
FOR EXAMPLE HAS. WE'RE STILL
WEARING FEES EVEN THOUGH DOCTOR
FOUND G. HIMSELF IS TESTIFYING
IN CONGRESS WITHOUT ONE. I'M
NOT SURE WHAT MESSAGE THAT
SENDS. BUT THE OTHER PART OF
THE PROBLEM. IS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN PLANNING FOR FAILURE. IN
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ESTIMATED THAT
UNEMPLOYMENT WOULD BE EIGHT
POINT 5% FOR THIS ENTIRE YEAR.
AT THE TIME SOME STATES ALREADY
HAD AN UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HALF
OF THAT. AND OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS SAYING EIGHT POINT
5% FOR THE YEAR IN THE SAME
DOCUMENT. IT FORECAST THAT
UNEMPLOYMENT WOULD NOT RETURN
TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS INTO THE
TWO TILL TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FIVE. A FIVE YEAR RECOVERY. SO
THAT IS THE ECONOMIC CONTEXT
FOR TODAY'S BUDGET. IS ECONOMIC
MALAISE THAT WAS CONSCIOUSLY
PLANNED AND IS BEING NEEDLESSLY
PERPETUATED. SO I WANT TO GIVE
YOU A DESCRIPTION OF THE BUDGET
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OWN WORDS
HERE'S HOW HE DESCRIBES THIS
CALIFORNIA COMEBACK PLANHE
SAID MORE DOLLAR SIGNS DOLLAR
SIGNS FOR STIMULUS CHECK MORE
DOLLAR SIGN DOLLAR SIGN FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES MORE DOLLAR
SIGN DOLLAR SIGN FOR OUR KIDS.
MORE DOLLAR SIGN DOLLAR SIGN TO
CLEAN OUR STREETS MORE DOLLAR
SIGN DOLLAR SIGN TO FIGHT
WILDFIRES I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THAT IS BUT IT'S NOT
GOVERNING. IT'S NOT LEADERSHIP
AND YOU DON'T NEED TO TAKE MY
WORD FOR THAT. LISTEN TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OWN MENTAL HEALTH
CZAR. WHO SAID THAT THE PROBLEM
WHEN IT COMES TO HOMELESS IT'S
NOT A MONEY PROBLEM. IT'S A
LEADERSHIP PROBLEM YEAH HERE WE
ARE THROWING TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS MORE AT IT. WITHOUT
ACTUALLY FINDING ANY REAL
SOLUTIONS. REAL POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP WOULD SEEK TO GET
OUR ECONOMY BACK AT FULL TILT
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WHILE
PROVIDING A FOUNDATION FOR A
SUSTAINED RECOVERY. THAT WOULD
INCLUDE FINANCIAL RELIEF. THAT
IS MEANT TO PROVIDE A REAL
SOCIAL SAFETY NET WHERE IT'S
NEEDED BUT PROVIDES THE RIGHT
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO RETURN TO WORK AND BY
THE WAY THAT INCLUDES MAKING
SURE PARENTS CAN RETURN TO
WORK. BY HAVING EVERY SCHOOL IN
THE STATE BE OPEN FULL TIME FOR
THIS COMING SCHOOL YEAR. NO
EXCUSES. THERE IS SO MUCH OTHER
LOW HANGING FRUIT IF WE HAD A
BUDGET THAT WAS GROWTH
ORIENTED. AND PUBLIC SPIRITED
WE COULD FORGIVE ALL COVERT
RELATED FINES PENALTIES AND
LICENSE REVOCATIONS. WE PROVIDE
LIABILITY PROTECTION FOR
BUSINESSES WE COULD REFORM PAGA
ANOTHER LITIGATION FRAPPES WE
CAN OFFER MEANINGFUL TAX RELIEF
SUCH AS NET OPERATING LOSS
CARRY BACKS. WE CAN REMOVE
ARBITRARY BARRIERS TO WORK.
LIKE AB FIVE WE CAN ADDRESS THE
SO CALLED SURPLUS WITH DURABLE
TAX REFORM. RATHER THAN RATHER
THAN ARBITRARY ONE TIME
PAYMENTS THIRTY SECONDS. FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YEARS THE
POPULATION OF THE STATE GREW.
THIS LAST YEAR IT DECLINED BY A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE. WE JUST LOST A SEAT IN
CONGRESS FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER THIS USED TO BE THE STATE
WHERE ANYONE COULD GET AHEAD
IT'S NOW THE STATE THAT MANY
CAN'T WAIT TO LEAVE BEHIND BUT
I FOR ONE. DON'T DO MY JOB AS
DIVVYING UP THE SPOILS ON A
SINKING HIP IT IS NOT TOO LATE
TO TURN THINGS AROUND IF WE
START MAKING BETTER CHOICES AND
I LOOK FORWARD AND I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THE DAY WILL SOON ARRIVE
WHEN CALIFORNIA CAN START
LEADING THE NATION. IN THE
RIGHT WAYS AGAIN. DR ARAMBULA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. THIS
BUDGET DOES NOT GET US BACK TO
NORMAL AS THAT WAS NOT OUR
INTENT BUT INSTEAD IT GETS US
TO A BETTER PLACE BY MAKING
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE FOR
CALIFORNIA. IT IS LONG BEEN
UNDERSTOOD THAT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH SOCIAL
INEQUITIES AND UNDER FUNDED
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM. AFFECTS
THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS. AND
IN THE INTEREST OF NOT LETTING
A GOOD CRISIS GO TO WASTE OUR
PLAN INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THESE ISSUES. I
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE BOLDNESS OF HIS LEADERSHIP
AND HIS VISION FOR OUR STATE
AND BY LEADING WITH A RESOURCE
MENTALITY. I WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP FOR THE
BUDGET OF OPPORTUNITY AND FOR
LEADING THE STATE IN A
DIRECTION AND PLACE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THE
MOST VULNERABLE CAN FIND A
BETTER PLACE THAN THEY HAVE
EVER BEEN IN BEFORE. I AM
THRILLED THAT THIS BUDGET
SUPPORTS HOPE FOR ALL EXPANDING
FULL SCOPE MEDICARE OLD
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS FOR THOSE THAT ARE OVER
THE AGE OF FIFTY. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT OUR STATE ACT NOW
TO PROTECT ALL LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY WERE BORN. THE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR PLAN
REFLECTS NOT ONLY THE CARE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THAT
PEOPLE NEED TODAY. BUT THE
CALIFORNIA THAT WE ALL WANT OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TO GROW
UP IN IN A POST PANDEMIC
FUTURE. I THANK YOU AND I URGE
YOUR VOTE FOR SB ONE TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU DOCTORING THAT
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES
AT THIS TIME. MISTER BASS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS ARRIVED
TODAY TO VOCALIZE MY
DISAPPOINTMENT IN THIS BUDGET.
SPECIFICALLY I'M DISAPPOINTED
IN THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
WITHIN THE PROCESS. AS YOU WILL
KNOW. THE MEASURES WERE VOTING
ON TODAY HAVE BARELY BEEN IN
FRONT SEVENTY TWO HOURS WHY WE
WAITED TILL SIX FIFTEEN TONIGHT
STEVEN GET THIS PROCESS STARTED.
OUR STAKEHOLDERS BACK HOME NO
NOT AT ADEQUATE TIME TO REVIEW
THESE MEASURES. AND
UNFORTUNATELY TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE. MOST OF THIS BILL IS SO
VAGUE THE NO ONE EVEN KNOWS.
WHAT IS REALLY IN IT WHAT THE
VERY SPECIFIC ITEMS DO. IN
WHERE THE DETAILED FUNDING GAPS.
MEMBERS WE JUST IGNORED. SIX
AMENDMENTS THAT COULD HELP
CLARIFY THAT. SIX AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS EDT
UNEMPLOYMENT THIS HUGE GAPPING
DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE IGNORED
LAID ON THE TABLE. BUDGET
STABILIZATION LAID ON THE TABLE.
WILDFIRE PREVENTION FUNDING IS
MISSION FROM MY COLLEAGUE IN
BAKERSFIELD MY DISTRICT ALONE
IS ALREADY HAD THREE WILDFIRES.
THIS WILDFIRE SEASON IS GOING
TO BE EVEN WORSE THAN THE LAST.
BUT AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
FUNDING FOR THAT TO ADD ACTUAL
TRANSPARENCY. BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE GOVERNOR'S WORD ON IT IT IS
FALSE. AND THAT'S BEEN LAID ON
THE TABLE. WATER STORAGE AND
CONVEYANCE. I REPRESENT THE
CITY WITHOUT WATER. I'VE
ALREADY HAD CALLS. LITTLE TOWN
A TEMPEST IN. YA CAN'T EVEN
FIND ON A MAP. OUR WATER WELLS
DRIED OUT. WHERE'S THE FUNDING
FOR THEM- LAID ON THE TABLE.
EDUCATION. MAKING SURE EVERY
STUDENT IS TRULY TAKING CARE OF
EVERY OPTION. SCHOOL CHOICE THE
ABILITY FOR OUR KIDS TO LEARN.
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THAT LAID
ON THE TABLE. AND OF COURSE THE
GAS TAX. LAID ON THE TABLE.
MEMBERS I DO APPLAUD. THE HARD
WORK OF A SELECT FEW
INDIVIDUALS. WHO CRAFTED THIS
BUDGET. BECAUSE THEY DID GET A
FEW THINGS RIGHT. SPECIFICALLY
THE FUNDING FOR ITV COMMUNITY.
FUNDS FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH.
AND INVESTMENTS INTO NEWER
HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGIES INSTEAD
OF PLACING ALL THE EGGS IN THE
ELECTRIFICATION BASKET. SO I DO
APPLAUD THAT. HOWEVER THERE'S
SO MUCH WRONG. WITH THIS BILL
BUT I COULD FRANKLY SPENT HOURS
GOING THROUGH IT BUT YOU ALL
LIKE YOU ONLY HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
THIS BUDGET DOES NOTHING TO
REDUCE OUR HIGH TAX RATES. AND
OFFERING MEANINGFUL RELIEF TO
STRUGGLING FAMILIES. WE ALWAYS
HEAR ABOUT INCREASE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE MINIMUM WAGE WE
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT HOW COME IT'S
SO EXPENSIVE IN CALIFORNIA HOW
DO WE HELP THESE FAMILIES WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO LOWER THE COST
OF LIVING FOR STRUGGLING
FAMILIES. I'VE BEEN TO REPORT.
I KNOW WHERE I COME FROM. I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE.
GOING TO THE STORE WAIT WITH
YOU I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS THE
EBT CHECK. AND HAVING TO GO AND
DO THAT. I KNOW WHAT THOSE
STRUGGLES ARE LIKE I KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO GO DO I GET THE
OIL CHANGED BY MY KID A NEW
PAIR OF SHOES. THIRTY SECONDS.
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT. BARTY
DISCUSS THE TAXES THE WILDFIRES
THE WATER THE RAINY DAY FUND.
MEMBERS DON'T YOU SCOLDED AS AN
EXCUSE AUGUST AND WITH THIS
THIS BILL OR VOTING ON TODAY.
IS A SLAP IN THE FACE OR
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM. THIS IS THE
LARGEST SHELL GAME. IN THE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE YEAR
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA. YA KNOW
BETTER THAN THIS YOUR COULD DO
BETTER THAN THIS NEVADA AMPLE
TIME IN THE ABILITY TO BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT. AND WE'VE
CHOSEN NOT TO. I ENCOURAGE YOU
ALL TO DO BETTER. VOTE NOW. MR
MCCARTY YOUR RECORD THANK YOU
YOU KNOW WE HAD A BIG DEBATE ON
THIS TWO WEEKS AGO AND OUR
BUDGET SHARED A NICE JOB OF
LAYING IT OUT SO I'LL TRY NOT
TO REPEAT BUT AGAIN THIS IS A
PRUDENT BUDGET WITH UPWARDS OF
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
RESERVE A REBOUNDING FOR THE
FUTURE BUT REALLY- FOCUSING ON
THE PRESENT AS WELL. IT WAS
SAID THAT THIS IS A
TRANSFORMATIONAL BUDGET YOU
COULD OVER USE THOSE WORDS IN
IN PUBLIC OFFICE BUT THIS
REALLY IS ONE OF THOSE BUDGETS
THIS IS THE BEST BUDGET FOR
EDUCATION IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA AND I WILL SAY THAT
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE DONE WE HAVE NOT STEPPED
UP FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS EARLY
EDUCATION FOR COLLEGE IT'S NOT
JUST THE LESS THE ACTIONS HERE
ARE PROVEN THAT WILL CHANGE
LIVES FROM EARLY EDUCATION AS
WAS NOTED. OVER HALF A MILLION
KIDS WELL ALL OF A SUDDEN HAVE
A CHANCE TO GO TO A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WITH
UNIVERSAL T. K. WITH EXPANDED
CHILD CARE WITH ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND SLOTS. A
VIABLE PROGRAMS THAT PAY THEIR
WORKERS A LIVING WAGE BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE THE
RATES FOR THESE PROGRAMS-
MAKING SURE WE EXPAND MORE OF
THESE SITES WITH ONE TIME MONEY
FOR FACILITIES. FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'RE
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL IN THE
FALL. NO MISTAKE WILL BE GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL IN THE FALL. AS
OUR BUDGET SHARE NOTED. RECORD
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
HIRE ENOUGH TEACHERS AND FIND
TRUE CLASS SIZE REDUCTION.
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS SO KIDS
WON'T GO TO SCHOOL HUNGRY NAKED
FOCUS ON LEARNING. AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS UNIVERSALLY SO PARENTS
CAN GO TO WORK. I KNOW THEIR
KIDS ARE TAKEN CARE OF AFTER
SCHOOL AND NOT GETTING IN
TROUBLE. EVERYBODY ON THIS
FLOOR ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT C. T.
E. HOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE. JOBS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO GO TO COLLEGE. ALL OF
YOU LOVE C. T. THIS BUDGETS
GOING TO DOUBLE. THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR CITY THAT'S ONE
THING GO BACK HOME TELL YOUR
PEOPLE YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
DOUBLING SUPPORT FOR C. T. FOR
COLLEGE. WE KNOW THAT THE
TICKET TO THE MIDDLE CLASS MORE
HIGHER EDUCATION WE NEED MORE
COLLEGE GRADUATES WE WANT
PEOPLE TO SUCCEED THIS. BILL
FULLY FUNDS OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WERE SUPER COLON
GROWTH. PROVIDES OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND NEW SLOTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO GO TO UC AND
CSU. AS OUR BUDGETARY NOTED
EARLIER WE GET SLAMMED EVERY
YEAR BECAUSE TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS APPLY TO YOU SEE.
AND CAN'T GET IN AND ADD INSULT
TO INJURY OUT OF STATE STUDENTS
TAKE THEIR SLOTS IN LA SAN
DIEGO IN BERKELEY WE'RE GOING
TO REDUCE THOSE NUMBERS TO
EXPAND ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE'RE TRULY GOING TO FIND
FINANCIAL AID THAT MAKES
COLLEGE DEBT FREE IN CALIFORNIA
BY DRAMATICALLY EXPANDING OUR
CAL GRANT AND MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM SO THIS
REALLY IS A BUDGET. THAT AS OUR
SUB ONE SHARE PRINT FRESNO SAYS
DOESN'T JUST GET US BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE. BUT GETS US TO
WHERE WE WANT TO BE AND MAKE
SURE WE INVEST IN THE NEXT
GENERATION THANK YOU SB RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY MISS
RIVAS. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
SPEAK ABOUT OUR HISTORIC
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS.
THANKS TO THE INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT OF OUR BUDGET CHAIR AND
ARE BUDGET SUB FOR CHAIR. WE'RE
INVESTING SIGNIFICANTLY. TO
COMBAT OUR GROWING HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. OF THIS BUDGET INCLUDES
FUNDING ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER. AND STRICT
ACCOUNTABILITY OVER THE TWO
YEARS WHILE THIS IS A FANTASTIC
START WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE'S
MORE TO DO BUT I KNOW THAT. ALL
OF US CARE ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND
WE WILL ASSURE. THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK. ON ENDING THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN OUR
STATE. NEXT I'M VERY PROUD. THE
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIRST STATE
IN THE NATION. TO PROVIDE
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL
CHILDREN. WE SHOULD ALL BE VERY
PROUD OF THAT WE ARE ENDING.
THE STRESS THAT A CHILD HAS. AT
SCHOOL WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO PAY FOR A LUNCH. THEY
WILL BE PREPARED ALL CHILDREN
WILL BE PREPARED. AND WILL NOT
BE HUNGRY AT SCHOOL WORK AND
DEAN. THAT STRUGGLE FOR A LOT
OF FAMILIES IN OUR STATE. AND
WE SHOULD B IS ALL SO PROUD OF
THAT. THANK YOU TO- THE SENATE
BUDGET CHAIR OF FOR. MAKING
THIS A PRIORITY IN THE SENATE
AND FOR OUR BUDGET CHAIR. FOR
ALSO DOING THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MYSTERIOUS MISTER
GIBSON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS OF THAT WE CAN
STOP USING HIS MASK- LET ME
JUST REAL ONLINE MY COMMENTS
WITH- THE MEMBER FROM
SACRAMENTO IN THE MEMBER FROM
LOS ANGELES I THINK THERE'S A
LOT IN HIS BUDGET- THAT WE CAN
ALL BE EXCITED ABOUT WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK. OF
OUR BUDGET. OUR GOVERNOR OUR
SPEAKER AMID ALL THE STAFF THAT
IS PLAYED A TREMENDOUS ROLE IN
GETTING US TO THIS PLACE WE
TALK ABOUT HISTORIC RECORD
NUMBERS OF RESOURCES GOING AND
STEPPING UP AND BEING COUNTED
FOR SO MANY CLIFORNIANS- I
WANT TO SAY THAT- I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE MEDICARE L. N.
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS FIFTY. A
PLUS REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
ANSWERED PRAYER. I MET SOME
WOMEN THE GREAT LEADERS THE
CAPITAL WITH OUR DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND SO MANY OTHERS WE
HAD ICON. ARCONIC INDIVIDUAL
STANDING WITH US. DR ABDULLAH
A. B. FOUR I'M A PROUD GOING
OFF OF THAT AND THAT'S IN THE
BILL INTHIS BUDGET- LANGUAGE
TODAY BUT SOME VERY COURAGEOUS
INDIVIDUALS. THIS ONE LADY WHO
STEP WITH ME SHE TALKED ABOUT
HOW SHE NEEDS SHE'S
UNDOCUMENTED. BUT SHE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT. THIS BEING HAVING
JUST FEELING A PART OF. AND
HOW. THE PASSAGE OF AB FOUR
WILL CERTAINLY BUT THOSE ARE
UNDOCUMENTED BE AN ANSWERED
PRAYER. DELORES WORKED TO STAY
WITH US ON THAT DAY. AND SHE
TALKED ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
STANDING UP. FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS. AND
CERTAINLY IN THIS BUDGET TODAY
REFLECTS THAT'S- BEDROSIAN
WE'RE STANDING UP FOUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WHETHER NOT WE KNOW
THEIR NAMES MAKES NO DIFFERENCE
WHETHER OR NOT OUR BLOODLINE IS
CONNECTED THERE'S MAKES NO
DIFFERENCE WE'RE STANDING UP
AND THIS. BILL IS BUDGET.
ABSOLUTELY EXEMPLIFY. THAT THEY
MATTER THEY MATTER TO EACH AND
EVERY CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE
THERE ARE EXTENDED BROTHERS AND
SISTERS THEY ARE OURS YOUR
ANSWER OUR GRANDMOTHERS. AND
TODAY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKING SURE THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
BEYOND THE AGAIN THERE ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SHE LOOKED AT ME
WITH TEARS IN HER OFFICE AND
SHE SAID DO WHAT WE CAN AND
TODAY IS A DEMONSTRATION OF US
DOING WE CAN. TODAY WE ANSWERED
HER PRAYER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE ON AB ONE TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I AM. AND STRUCK BY MANY OF THE
COMMENTS ACROSS THE- PARTISAN
DIVIDE ON THIS FLOOR AND IN
TERMS OF HIS BUDGET I MEAN I
FEEL LIKE I'M LISTENING TO A
CABLE NEWS. YOU KNOW I DO
BELIEVE THAT THAT THIS IS.
PROBABLY AS GOOD AS IT'S GOING
TO GET IN TERMS OF. A BUDGET
THAT WE CAN PASS IN TERMS OF
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING. I N. HEALTHCARE AND
EDUCATION AND FIGHTING
HOMELESSNESS ON SO MANY
DIFFERENT FRONTS. AND SO I WILL
PROUDLY SUPPORT THIS BILL- BUT-
YOU KNOW I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THAT- YOU KNOW IT IT
THERE ARE SOME POINTS OF
CONCERN. THAT IS- TO CROSS
PARTY LINES YOU KNOW I DO WISH
THAT THERE WAS MORE FUNDING IN
THIS BUDGET TO ADDRESS WILDFIRE
PREVENTION YOU KNOW I HEAR. MY
COLLEAGUE- REPRESENTING
PARADISE TO WHICH YOU WANT TO
AVOID. THE YOU KNOW IT IT TWO
TWO. BASICALLY WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE SPENDING MORE FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION BECAUSE- I
MEAN IT'S- WE ARE SO WE ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES IN AND SEEING
THE CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE
CHANGE RIGHT HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- WE NEED TO
FEEL THAT MORE OF THAT SENSE OF
URGENCY AND FIGHTING THE
WILDFIRES WE NEED TO SPEND MORE
MONEY TO REDUCE THE FUEL TO
FIGHT. WILDFIRES AND ON THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS. YOU KNOW
I AS AS MUCH AS I WELCOME THE
RECORD AMOUNT OF SPENDING. TO
FIGHT HOMELESSNESS YEAH I WANT
TO SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE ON
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. WE HAVE PASSED MEASURES
LIKE MEASURE H. AND MEASURE HHH
WERE THE TAXPAYERS OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. HAVE AFFIRMATIVELY
VOTED WITH OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY TO INCREASE TAXES ON
THEMSELVES TO FIGHT. THIS
HOMELESS CRISIS THAT WE'RE
SEEING YOU KNOW. APPEARING IN
SO MANY OF OUR OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SO MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND YET WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS GETTING LARGER AND
LARGER IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES NOW I KNOW
THAT. HOMELESSNESS IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE THAT THAT THE
IT'S LIKELY. THAT YOU KNOW
TRYING TO CAPTURE WATER WITH
THE NET THAT THERE'S SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT CONTINUE TO FALL
INTO HOMELESSNESS EVEN AS WE
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
IN BUILDING MORE. PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS WELL AS
TEMPORARY SHELTERS. BUT I JUST
HOPE YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN I WAS
LISTEN TO THE BUDGET SHARE
PRESENTING. THIS BILL AND THE
BUDGET. COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY
THAT IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE DETAILS IN TERMS OF
THE HOMELESS SPENDING YOU KNOW
ARE STILL TO BE DETERMINED
ESPECIALLY THE DETAILS IN TERMS
OF ACCOUNTABILITY IN IN TERMS
OF THE SPENDING. IT UP WE CAN'T
JUST SHOVEL MONEY AT THE
PROBLEM. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING
WELL SPENT. IT ALL IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE'VE WE'VE HAD
REPORTS THE LOS ANGELES
CONTROLLER CAME OUT OF REPORT
SAYING THAT THE AVERAGE COST OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
IS ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT. AND HIGHER
WHEREAS I KNOW THAT TO IT AND
MY COMMUNITIES THE CITY OF
REDONDO BEACH FOR EXAMPLE I
MEAN THEY'VE THEY'VE STEPPED UP
THEIR THEIR- THEY THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE A CREATED- A PILOT
PROJECT TO. TO- BUILD V. THE
PALACE SHELTERS THE THAT THE
TEMPORARY SHELTERS THAT ARE
THAT ARE SUPPORTED WITH THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT WE
NEED THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. THOSE EACH ONE OF
THOSE UNITS COSTS ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ACCORDING TO
THE CITY OF REDONDO BEACH TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT NOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOU KNOW
WHAT SOME PEOPLE CALL A TOOL
SHED. VERSUS PERMANENT HOUSING
BUT THE FACT IS THAT YOU KNOW
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO DELAY AND
GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
THE PEOPLE ARE DYING EVERY DAY
ON THE STREETS PEOPLE THAT ARE
LIVING IN THIS TENSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE LIVING ON THE STREETS.
YOU KNOW AT LEAST THESE THESE
TOOL SAYS THESE PALACE. YOU
KNOW SHELTERS IT'S A IT'S A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD WHEN IT'S
RAINING WHEN THE WHEN THE
WEATHER'S BAD IT'S A CLEAN BED
AND IS MOST IMPORTANTLY IS
SUPPORTED WITH THESE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. SO WE CAN DO BOTTOM
LINE IS WE CAN DO BETTER IN
TERMS OF MAKING PROGRESS IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST HOMELESSNESS WE
CAN'T JUST SHOVEL MONEY AT THE
PROBLEM WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING
WELL SPENT. AND SO I HOPE THAT
THE TRIP OF THE FORTHCOMING
TRAILER BILL ON THE ON THE
HOMELESS SPENDING WILL PROVIDE
FOR THAT ACCOUNTABLE ABILITY SO
AT THE VERY LEAST NO SO THAT WE
KNOW HOW THOSE DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT. RATHER THAN JUST
YOU KNOW GIVING A BLANK CHECKS
TO OUR OUR OUR LOCAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO FIGHT THIS CRISIS.
MISTER ROSS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOUNG MAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK THIS- LEGISLATURE ALSO
FOR THE FIRST TIME. IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE MOVING
FORWARD- WITHIN THE BUDGET TO
START TO ADDRESS. THE ISSUE OF
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO MOVE
FORWARD. TO MAKE SURE THAT ONCE
AND FOR ALL THAT VOICE IS NOT.
BEING SILENCE AS FAR AS THOSE
CRIMES ARE BEINGCOMMITTED.
AGAINST NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
NOT ONLY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT IS HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. AND AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES FORWARD WITHIN
THE BUDGET TO PUT PRIORITIES.
OF ALL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE
MISSING AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN STARS TO SERVE
AS A MODEL IN A ROLE. FOR ALL
OTHER STATES IN THE IN THE
NATION TO FOLLOW SUIT. I WANT
TO THANK THIS LEGISLATURE IN ON
BEHALF OF ALL THOSE MISSING
PERSONS ON NATIVE AMERICAN
LANDS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT FOR PUTTING THE
PRIORITIES. FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE LEADING BY
EXAMPLE BY MAKING SURE THAT NO
ONE IS LEFT BEHIND AND THAT
INCLUDES THE MISSING AND
MURDERED. NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
IN THE NATION AND IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER ROBERTS I MISS
CARILLO YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK OUR BUDGET CHAIR AS WELL
AS THE INCREDIBLE BUDGET STAFF
WHO HAS HAS. RESTLESS DAY THAN
RESTLESS NIGHTS TRYING TO GET
THROUGH ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS COMING BACK AND FORTH
TO ENSURE THAT THIS AT THE END
OF THE DAY THIS BUDGET REFLECTS
THE PEOPLE'S VALUES WE HAVE LED
IN THE BUDGET THAT IS ABOUT
EQUITY. EQUITY IN ALL KINDS OF
TERMS WHETHER IT'S HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS HISTORIC
PRESERVATION EFFORTS MOVING
FORWARD EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION K. THROUGH TWELVE
AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING COLLEGE
READINESS ALL KINDS OF PROGRAMS
THAT ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BUT I DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
IT IS THANKS TO THE DIRECTION
AND LEADERSHIP OF OUR SPEAKER
AND SO MANY OF OUR FEMALE
LEGISLATORS THAT HAVE ALSO BEEN
PUT IN POSITIONS. OF
CHAIRMANSHIPS- IN COMMITTEES
THAT HAVE LED IN A WAY THAT IS
BOTH POLICY DRIVEN BUDGET
DRIVEN AND IS ABLE TO ALIGN
THIS BUDGET WITH THE VALUES AND
TESTAMENTS OF THE STATE AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY THIS BUDGET
WILL BE REFLECTIVE. OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE AND SOME
HAVE SAID YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
PUT MORE MONEY IN THE RESERVE
BECAUSE WE NEED IT FOR A RAINY
DAY WELL GUESS WHAT. IT'S BEEN
RAINING FOR A LONG TIME FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND THIS MONEY IS
NEEDED RIGHT NOW TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE SAFETY
AND REASSURANCE TO THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE THAT CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME AND THAT THIS
BUDGET AT THE END OF THE DAY IS
AIMED TO HELP ALL OF THEM WE
ARE TOGETHER. CREATING A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND NOT A
CALIFORNIA FOR SOME AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
KOREA THANK YOU MEMBERS I SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MISTER TANK YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER LET ME JUST
THANK ALL OUR COLLEAGUES FOR
THIS VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS INCREDIBLE
BUDGET I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL
THE MEMBERS WHO SIT. ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WHO SIT IN THE
SUB COMMITTEE AND SIT THERE FOR
HOURS AND HOURS LISTENING TO
TESTIMONY ON EVERY SINGLE FACET
OF THIS BUDGET WE HAD OVER
SIXTY HEARINGS THIS YEAR LET ME
THANK OUR VARIOUS FIVE SUB
CHAIRS OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FRESNO SACRAMENTO SANTA MONICA
LOS ANGELES BELL GARDENS ALL
FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK
THROUGH THIS BUDGET PROCESS FOR
ME THANK. OUR VICE CHAIR FROM
BAKERSFIELD OF FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT HE PUTS INTO THIS BUDGET
THANK ARE OUR SPEAKER IN THE
BACK THERE REALLY FOR HIS
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP HIS WHOLE
TEAM IN PARTICULAR FOR JASON
SIDNEY THEY ARE THE ALL THE
WORK THAT HE PUTS IN. CHRISTIAN
GRIFFITH IS THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT OF ARE SIMPLY-
BUDGET COMMITTEE AS WELL AS ALL
OUR BUDGET TEAM HAVE PUT IN
JUST A COUNTLESS HOURS NOT JUST
THE LAST MONTH OR TWO BUT
REALLY GOING BACK- BEGINNING
INTO THE FALL OF LAST YEAR LET
ME ALSO. THANK JOE SINCE STOCK
JOCHEN STOCK IN THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
HARD WORK THIS REALLY IS A TEAM
EFFORT I THINK YOU HEAR ABOUT
ON THIS PARTICULAR FLOOR MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE DON'T
AGREE ON BUT THERE IS AGAIN SO
MUCH THAT WE DO AGREE ON WITHIN
THIS BUDGET AS WE MOVE FORWARD
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LET ME ALSO THANK ARE ILLEGAL
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ALL THE SUPPORT OFFICES FOR
THIS INCREDIBLE WORKERS BUDGET
DOESN'T GET PUT DONE IN ONE DAY
IT'S HOURS AND HOURS OF WORK
WITH HUNDREDS OF HUNDREDS OF
STAFF TO REALLY MAKE THIS A
REALITY SO LET ME AGAIN JUST
THANK YOU ALL FOR. YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THAT THIS IS A
MOMENT THAT I THINK IT WE
SHOULD ALL ENJOY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
VOTE ON SB ONE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MICHELLE. A WITHOUT
THE CAR WILL THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ASIDE OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF A. DESIRABLE.
THE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE KNOWS
TWELVE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE THIS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND THAT
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA THE
FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
HOLD AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
ON THURSDAY JULY FIRST. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I REQUEST IS GRANTED.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY NINTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY JUNE
THIRTIETH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY JULY THE FIRST. FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL
BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING OR FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MAYES RAMOS MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY JULY FIRST. AT NINE AM
AND THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.